चलिए
[संगीत]
तो ओके आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ
अ लेट्स सी लाइव आ गए क्या हम एम आई लाइव
गाइस एक बार बता दीजिए हेलो हेलो
एवरीवन हेलो
एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस एम आई ऑडिबल
विजिबल क्लियर है सब कुछ
जल्दी से बता
दीजिए ऑडिबल विजिबल एवरीथिंग इज फाइन
चलिए
ओके ओके लेट मी चेक एक बार मैं भी चेक कर
लेता हूं आपके साथ साथ ओके हम लाइव आ चुके
हैं सॉरी
एंड ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ सही है ऑडियो
एकदम क्लियर है ना भाई वीडियो एकदम क्लियर
है सभी लोग बता दीजिए जल्दी ठीक है ठीक है
चलिए वेलकम वेलकम वेलकम एवरी
बडी तो वेलकम एवरी बडी टू क्लास 10 डे 10
ऑफ बग
बाउंटीज एंड स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं बता
दूं कि मैंने यह गोगल्स क्यों लगा रखा है
क्योंकि सामने लाइट्स होती है बहुत ज्यादा
लाइट्स आती है आंखों प तो ट्स वई थोड़ा सा
इससे प्रोटेक्शन मिल जाता है ठीक है और
कोई बात नहीं है चलिए सभी लोग को जाने
देते एक
बार
ओके ओके आई होप
कि कितने लोग आ गए हैं ओके 30 अभी 33 है
36 है ठीक है चलिए सो क्या हाल है आप सबके
एंड गुड इवनिंग सबको वेलकम टू क्लास 10
एंड क्लास नाइ तक आप सबने आई होप रिवाइज
किए होंगे वीडियोस को देखे होंगे वापस से
आपने वीडियोस देखे होंगे रिवाइज किए होंगे
क्लासेस जो आपको नहीं समझ में आया होगा
एंड आपको उसमें कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं आ रही
होगी ठीक है अगर कोई प्रॉब्लम आ भी रही है
तो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है हमारा जो फ्री
कोर्स है ए ए ट्रॉनिक्स अकेडमी के अंदर
में जो र वाला उसके अंदर आपके डाउट सेशन
होंगे जब होगा आपको नोटिफाई कर दिया जाएगा
उसको जॉइन कीजिए जो भी डाउट्स है जो भी
सवाल है वहां पूछ सकते हैं ठीक
है
चलिए ओके गाइस
तो
ओके गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
चलिए बढ़िया
बढ़िया तो आज का सेशन बहुत ज्यादा
इंटरेक्ट प्रैक्टिकल एंड बहुत ही ज्यादा
अमेजिंग होने वाला है क्योंकि आज हम एक
वल्नरेबल के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं जो
कि बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग है एंड आप डे
टू डे लाइफ में जब आप वलने बिलिटी
एक्सप्लोर करते हैं जब आप बग बाउंट करते
हैं उस टाइम पे आप इस वनबिल के लिए भी जा
सकते हैं सबसे पहले एंड जैसे ही सब डोमेन
आपने फाइंड कर लिया उसके बाद यू कैन लुक
फॉर दिस पर्टिकुलर वल्नरेबल एंड ये
वल्नरेबल जनरली काफी सारे वेब एप्लीकेशन
में प्रेजेंट रहती हैं एंड आपको एक
बाउंटीज स्वैग भी दिला सकती हैं यह बात की
मैं आपको गारंटी देता हूं बट इस वलने
बिलिटी को समझने के लिए आपको कुछ इसके की
पॉइंट समझने पड़ेंगे नहीं तो आपको बिल्कुल
भी समझ में नहीं आने वाला है ठीक
है वयर आर यू फ्रॉम आई एम बेसिकली फ्रॉम
बिहार
चलिए तो स्टार्ट करने से पहले गाइस अ लेट
मी इंट्रोड्यूस सम ऑफ आवर सोशल मीडिया
हैंडल्स ये हमारा
linkedin.com
company.in पेज है इसको फॉलो जरूर कर
लीजिएगा क्योंकि जितने भी अपडेट्स है
कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग फ्री कोर्सेस जो
अपकमिंग आएंगे फ्री जो भी अपकमिंग हमारे
ट्रेनिंग आने वाले हैं या जो भी क्लासेस
शुरू होने वाले हो सब इसी पे आएगा या
कंपनी के जो भी डेवलपमेंट अपडेट्स हैं इसी
पे आएंगी यह हमारे ही कंपनी का
साइबर सिक्योरिटी की टीम डेनिक्स इसका
हैंडल है आप इसके आके फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
क्योंकि
twitter.com यहां ब्लॉग सेक्शन पे आके
बढ़िया-बढ़िया ब्लॉग्स आर्टिकल्स पढ़ सकते
हैं काफी नॉलेज आपको मिल जाएगी एंड जो लोग
हमारे अकेडमी पोर्टल पे विजिट करना चाहते
हैं अकेडमी पर क्लिक करके हमारे अकेडमी पे
आके हमारे कोर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं एंड द नेक्स्ट इज डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक
मास्टरी आप इस डोमेन पे france.com
digitalf5 हैं डीसीएसपी डीसी जेएसपी हैं
एंड क्वालिफाइड ट्रेनर है जो कि थ्री
इयर्स की एक्सपीरियंस के साथ है एंड आपको
थ्री मंथ्स की वीकें ट्रेनिंग मिलने वाली
है इसके कोर्स की डिटेल्स यहां ब्राउज शयर
वगैरह डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं एंड देन आप इस
कोर्स के साथ जा सकते हैं एंड आप आपकी
डिटेल्स वगैरह सब कुछ यहां पे ही आपके आ
जाएगी ठीक है ओके यहां पे आके आप दे सकते
हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम सारी डिटेल देख सकते हैं
सारी चेकआउट वगैरह कर सकते हैं सब कुछ ये
सर्टिफिकेट आपको मिलेगी डीडीएफएस की
डिजिटल डेफॉक्स अ डिजिटल अ डेफॉक्स डिजिटल
फॉस स्पेशलिस्ट की एंड दिस वन यू विल गेट
आफ्टर कंप्लीट दिस ट्रेनिंग एंड काफी काफी
अफोर्डेबल प्राइस में आपको भी फिलहाल मिल
रहा है चलिए तो अब शुरू करते हैं हमारा
मेन जो फंडा है वो मेन फंडा हम स्टार्ट
करते हैं आज का एंड आज से आज जो बेसिकली
आज का जो सेशन होने वाला है इसमें हम
समझने वाले हैं सब डोमेन टेकओवर को काफी
टाइम से काफी लोग बोल रहे थे
कि सब डोमेन टेकओवर के बारे में बताइए
हमें सब डोमेन टेकओवर क्या होता है किस
तरीके से वी कैन अ प्रोसीड विद सब डोमन
टेकओवर कैसे ये हम फाइंड कर सकते हैं ये
वनबिल ये बग कैसे एक किसी वेब एप्लीकेशन
में हम फाइंड कर सकते हैं ये बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग वलने बिलिटी है बट ध्यान से
समझिए तो आपको एक-एक चीज मैं इसको ना
बेसिक से बताऊंगा इतना डीप बताऊंगा कि
आपको सब डोमेन टेकओवर
में कोई प्रॉब्लम कोई डाउट रहेगा ही नहीं
ठीक है भैया
बस ओके लाइक कर दिया सबने अरे यहां 70 लोग
है लगभग लाइक सिर्फ यार 50 या ना इंसाफी
कर द भाई वॉइस प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
भाई वॉइस प्रॉब्लम नहीं है मेरे ख्याल से
आपकी
होगी या आपके साइड की इशू होगी वो नेटवर्क
के कारण ठीक
है
ओके चलिए चलिए इंग्लिश सॉरी ब्रदर कैन नॉट
टेक दिस सेशन इन इंग्लिश बिकॉज ये हिंदी
का ही सेशन है तो हिंदी में ही होगा ठीक
है इंग्लिश का कभी आएगा कभी दूसरा चैनल
अगर हमने बनाया इंग्लिश पर्टिकुलर इंग्लिश
के लिए तो आपको वहां पे मिलेगा चलिए अब सब
डोमन टेक ओवर के बारे में पहले समझते हैं
एंड आई होप इसके पहले आपने डे नाइन तक के
वीडियोस कंप्लीट कर लिए और अपने दोस्तों
के भी शेयर की है अब आप में से बता दीजिए
कितने लोग शेयर करते हैं जरा चैट में
क्योंकि क्योंकि शेयर करेंगे तो हमारी
वीडियोस काफी लोगों तक पहुंचेगा यह फ्री
कंटेंट है इसके बदले मुझे क्या मिल रहा है
कुछ नहीं सब्सक्राइबर्स मिल रहे हैं एक
फैमिली मिल रही है एक डिफ्रॉक स्टर्स की
फैमिली मिल रही है एक हमारा चैनल का यूजर
बेस बढ़ रहा है और हमारी चैनल पॉपुलर हो
रही है ये मेरे को मिल रहा है इतना मुझे
पता है ठीक है एंड इसके बदले में थोड़ा
बहुत
$ के आते हैं ठीक है उसके अलावा कुछ नहीं
उसके अलावा जो भी चीज आपको मिल रही है
फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट मिल रही है आपसे एक रुपया
भी नहीं चार्ज किया जा रहा है आपसे आपका
टाइम लिया जा रहा है एंड उस टाइम में आपको
कुछ प्रोडक्टिव स्किल्स प्रोवाइड किए जा
रहे हैं बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट ठीक है
चलिए थैंक यू सो मच सब डोमेन टेकओवर क्या
होता है इसको पहले समझते हैं बहुत ही बहुत
ही माइन्यूट समझते
हैं सबसे पहले लेट्स सपोज मेरी एक वेबसाइट
है fix.com
यह मेरी एक वेबसाइट है
इसका एक सब डोमेन है
हेडिन कॉ ये इसका सब डोमेन है चलिए ठीक है
व्ट इ दिस सब डोमेन ऑफ क अब मान लो कि
हेल्ड de.com जो है ना यह किसी थर्ड
पार्टी क्लाउड सर्विस को यूज कर रही है
कोई सा भी सर्विस हो सकता है थर्ड पार्टी
क्लाउड सर्विस जैसे गिट हब हो सकता है ग
क्लाउड हो सकती है अन क्लाउड हो सकता
है ठीक है
अ अनबाउंस हो सकता
है ठीक है यह भी हो सकता है अन है यह
अमेजन नहीं है यह अन क्लाउड हो सकता है
अनबाउंस हो सकता है अजर हो सकता है
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट अजर भी आपका हो सकता है ठीक
है नेटलिफाई हो सकता है आपका व्हाट एवर जो
भी सर्विसेस जो क्लाउड सर्विस प्रोवाइड
करती है वह
सारे सर्विसेस हमारा यह सब डोमेन यूज कर
सकता है किसी पर्टिकुलर थर्ड पार्टी
क्लाउड सर्विस को अपनी कुछ सर्विसेस को
होस्ट करने के लिए उस पर्टिकुलर क्लाउड
सर्विस में समझ में आ
गया वॉइस प्रॉब्लम हो रही है क्या
अ नारायण ब्लॉग्स नयन ब्लॉग्स आप स्पैम मत
कीजिए अदर वाइज मुझे आपको टाइम आउट में
डालना पड़ जाएगा फिर आप कर नहीं पाएंगे
कमेंट प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट इफ देयर इज
अ वॉइस प्रॉब्लम सभी लोग बोलेंगे नहीं तो
वॉइस प्रॉब्लम मुझे नहीं लग रही कोई वॉइस
प्रॉब्लम यहां पे है ठीक है क्योंकि मुझे
बिल्कुल क्लियर आ रही है आवाज मेरे को खुद
की मैं भी सुन रहा हूं ना दूसरे डिवाइस प
राइट सो आई थिंक एवरीथिंग इज ओके राइट
चलिए
ओके help.com हमारे इस इन क्लाउड सर्विसेस
का इन क्लाउड सर्विसेस का यूज कर सकती है
किसी थर्ड पार्टी सर्विस होस्ट करने के
लिए क्या करने के लिए टू टू होस्ट होस्ट
सम सर्विसेस ऑन ऑन दीज थर्ड
पार्टी
क्लाउड क्लाउड सर्विसेस ठीक है अब चलो अब
मान लो
help.com ने इन क्लाउड सर्विसेस में से
किसी एक का जैसे मान लो गिट हब का यूज कर
लिया अपने सर्विसेस को होस्ट करने के लिए
इस पे अब भैया इसका मतलब यह हुआ इसका मतलब
यह हुआ कि जब भी कोई बंदा हेल्प डॉट
fix.com पर जाए तो
वो गिट हब पर जो सर्विस हमारी चल रही है
उसको फेच
करें तभी तो कोई फायदा है ना help.com इस
सब डोमेन को इस सर्विस से टैग करने का तभी
तो कोई फायदा है अरवाज क्या फायदा है तो
यानी help.com प कोई जाए तो यह हमारे गिट
हब सर्विस
को रीच
टू गिट हब सर्विस जो हम यूज कर रहे हैं जो
हमने वहां पे बेसिकली होस्ट कर रखा है यही
होना चाहिए अब यह कैसे
होगा हाउ इ दिस पॉसिबल कि कोई इस डोमेन को
ओपन करे बट यहां की सर्विस पर रीच
करे यह होता है यह पॉसिबल है ड्यू टू
रीडायरेक्शन किस चीज से पॉसिबल है
रीडायरेक्शन
से लेकिन रीडायरेक्शन का मतलब क्या होता
है कि
help.com से कहीं और चले जाना किसी और
डोमेन पे इसका मतलब तो यही होता है तो अब
यहां प्रॉपर रीडायरेक्शन की बात नहीं हो
रही है यहां बात हो रही है
रीडायरेक्शन
प्लस सर्विस
शोकेश या रिजल्ट जो सर्विस है उसका रिजल्ट
या शोकेस करना इस पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन के
लिए एंड यह काम करती है एक एंटिटी एक
रिकॉर्ड जो कि डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड होती है
आपकी जिसका नाम होता है सी नेम इसको हम
बोलते हैं कैनो निकल नेम सी नेम इसका काम
क्या है मैप वन डोमेन टू अनदर विदाउट
गिविंग एनी आईपी एड्रेस समझ में आ गया
भैया इसका यही काम है सी नेम का काम है
क्या काम नाम है भैया कैनॉनिकल नेम जिसको
बोलते हैं मैप वन डोमेन टू अनदर विदाउट
गिविंग एनी आईपी एड्रेस मतलब एक डोमेन या
सब डोमेन को दूसरे डोमेन या सब डोमेन पे
मैप कर देना बस और कुछ भी नहीं जैसे कि आप
कोई सर्विस आप क्या कर रहे हो आपने एक
एड्रेस को मान लो आपके घर के एड्रेस को
किसी दूसरे एड्रेस पे मैप कर दिया यानी कि
आपके घर के एड्रेस प कोई आ रहा है तो वो
दूसरे एड्रेस प पहुंच जाएगा जैसे कि आप
कॉल फॉरवर्डिंग भी करते हो एक तरह से तो
एक तरह की वही बात हो गई कि आपने एक नंबर
को दूसरे नंबर पे फॉरवर्ड कर दिया अब उस
नंबर पे जो कॉल करेगा तो दूसरे पे
ऑटोमेटिक फ उसकी सर्विस को यूज करने लगेगा
बस यही चीज यहां हो रही है कि यहां पे जब
हम सी नेम रिकॉर्ड की बात करते हैं इसका
मतलब है कि हेल्प df.com किसी और सब डोमेन
पे भी मैप हो सकता है एंड उसकी सर्विस को
यूटिलाइज की जा सकती है इतना समझने में
कोई दिक्कत आ रहा है आपको पहले मुझे बताइए
फिर आगे बढूंगा नहीं तो कचड़ा हो जाएगा
चलिए बताइए
जल्दी बता दीजिए इतने समझने में कोई
दिक्कत प्लीज लेट मी नो
गाइस जल्दी बता
दीजिए
समझ में आ रहा
इतना यस सर यस
[संगीत]
सर
सॉरी सर मैं अभी डे फ पर
हूं क्या मैं डे सिक्स देखू या फिर डे
सिक्स देखो एंड इसको कंटिन्यू रखो लेकिन
डे सिक्स को भी देख देखना
जरूर ठीक
है
ओके ठीक है समझ समझ में आ रहा है ठीक
है ओके वेरी गुड इफ यू आर इफ यू आर गेटिंग
एवरीथिंग चलो एक हार्ट एक हार्ट का सिंबल
है आपके नीचे कमेंट बॉक्स के पास वहां से
एक हार्ट दे दो जल्दी से समझ में आ जाएगा
कि आपको सब समझ में आ रहा है ठीक है चलिए
अरे बिना री विदाउट रीडायरेक्ट मतलब बिना
मैपिंग के आप 302 31 जो भी है वो कर सकते
हो एचटी एक्सेस फाइल के थ्रू भी कर सकते
हो वैसे भी बहुत सारी सर्विसेस एंड टूल्स
आते हैं उसके प्लगइन आते हैं ठीक है चलिए
तो ये सी नेम का यही काम है अब मैं आपको
एक चीज दिखाता हूं सबसे पहले एंड देन आपको
शायद समझ में आ जाएगा एक काम करते हैं
व्हाट व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू मैं अपना
एक डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड आपके साथ शेयर करने
वाला हूं आप देखिए क्लाउड फ्लेयर ओपन करता
हूं मैं आई एम ओपनिंग क्लाउड फ्लेयर एंड
मैं लॉग इन कर रहा हूं मैं क्लाउड फयर की
सर्विस यूज कर रहा हूं हमारी एक वेबसाइट
के लिए सो होप
फुली मैं लॉगिन कर पाऊंगा क्योंकि मुझे
पासवर्ड याद है या नहीं आई डोंट नो देखते
हैं पासवर्ड लॉगिन हो पा रहा है कि नहीं
हो पा रहा है आई डाउट कि मुझे पासवर्ड याद
है
यस गलत हो गया शायद कोई बात नहीं
मैं एक दूसरा पासवर्ड डालता हूं देन ट्राई
करते हैं एंड यह भी गलत हो गया ठीक
है मैं एक तीसरा पासवर्ड डालता हूं देन
ट्राई करता हूं एंड ये सही हो गया चलिए
बढ़िया है यह सही हो गया हम क्लाउड फलेर
के डैशबोर्ड में लॉगइन है अब क्लाउड फ्लेर
क्या है बेसिकली ये भी एक क्लाउड सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर है एंड ये एक प्रॉक्सी
प्रोवाइडर भी आपका तो आप इसकी प्रॉक्सी को
यूज कर सकते हैं एंड एज अ डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड
मैनेजर ये काम करेगा आपका डीएनएस सारा
मैनेज करेगा ट्रैफिक इसके थ्रू आपकी जो है
मैनेज हो जाएगी तो टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
वेबसाइट जो है हमारी बेसिकली ये वेबसाइट
की मैं बात कर रहा हूं यहां पे टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर सर्च कर लो
google.in हमारी ठीक है तो इस वेबसाइट की
इस वेबसाइट में हमने क्लाउड फर सेटअप कर
रखा है एंड इसकी यहां पे डीएनएस एंट्री
मैं आपको दिखाने जा रहा हूं ठीक है आपको
बहुत कुछ दिखा दे रहा हूं मैं ये शुक्र
मना हो ठीक है अब ये डीएनएस एंट्री में आप
देखोगे कि कुछ रिकॉर्ड्स की एंट्रीज है ए
रिकॉर्ड दिख रहा है आपको सी नेम रिकॉर्ड
आपको दिख रहा है एमए रिकॉर्ड आपको दिख रहा
है टी एकटी रिकॉर्ड दिख रहा है ये सारे
डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स होते हैं इससे हमारा जो
है ना बेसिकली डीएनएस मैनेज होता है एक
तरह से ठीक है अब बहुत ज्यादा डीप उसमें
नहीं जाने वाले हैं फिलहाल के लिए ए
रिकॉर्ड का मतलब बेसिकली आपकी जो रूट
सर्वर है उसकी आईपी को ये डिनोट करता है
आपका सी नेम रिकॉर्ड जो अभी मैंने आपको
बताया मैपिंग के लिए एए रिकॉर्ड मेल सर्वर
के रिकॉर्ड्स को अ डिनोट करता है टी एक्टी
रिकॉर्ड्स जो जो है वो मिसलेनियस रिकॉर्ड
होल्डर्स है जिसमें अलग-अलग ईमेल
सिक्योरिटीज एंड लाइक डीआरएम डीके आईएम यह
सब के जो जो भी रिकॉर्ड्स है इसमें आ जाते
हैं ठीक है चलिए अब इसमें हमें सी नेम से
मतलब है आप देख रहे होंगे यहां पे सी नेम
डाला हुआ है यहां पे एक यहां पे होस्ट
डाला हुआ है नेम जो भी है आप डाल दीजिए
यहां पे कंटेंट डाला हुआ है यहां पे या जो
भी लोकेशन है वो डाला हुआ है कुछ इस तरह
से चीजें हैं अब देखो इसी रिकॉर्ड में इस
पर्टिकुलर रिकॉर्ड में जहां पर सी नेम
आपने देखा तरह की रिकॉर्ड होती है जैसे
क्या होता है मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं जैसे
सीएम रिकॉर्ड जो होगा टिपिकल सीएम रिकॉर्ड
कैसे होगा यह मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं जैसे
एक पहले जो मेन सब डोमेन है वो होगा
हेल्प de.com कुछ इस तरीके से होगा उसके
बाद ये जिस पे पॉइंट कर रहा होगा उसका
डोमेन नेम यहां पे आ सकता है तो जैसे मैं
मान मान लेता हूं डिक्स मैं गिट हब यूज कर
रहा हूं डॉट
github.io मान लो ये यूज करो github.com
कुछ भी करो ये होता है एक तरह से ठीक है
इस तरीके से एंड यहां पे कोई टीटीएल
वैल्यू वगैरह जो होती है वो आपकी टीटीएल
वैल्यू आ जाती है कुछ इस तरह का रिकॉर्ड
होता है तो पहला जो सेक्शन होता है आपका
सब डोमेन होता है ठीक है दूसरा सेक्शन जो
होता है यह आपका वो सर्विस का सब डोमेन है
जो आप यूज कर रहे हो गिब के ऊपर यानी कि
आपने इसी डोमेन को गिट हब अपने सर्विस पे
कंफिल करा है जैसे मेरा मतलब यह है कि एक
गिट हब रिपोजिटरी है गिट हब रिपोजिटरी
है इसका नाम है डि फ्रक्स रेपो ये मान लो
डिफन रेपो करके टव रिपोजिटरी है चलो मैं
आपको इसका एग्जांपल भी दिखा देता हूं जैसे
हमारा टूल है ठीक है चलो साइरोनिक्स सर्च
करो साइबर सर्च करोगे तो आपको यहां पे
सीधा हमारी टूल ही जो है सबसे पहले रिजल्ट
में आएगी एंड आपको दिख रहा होगा टीम डि
फ्रक्स करके यहां पे ये टीम
डिफ्रॉक्ड में चलोगे यहां हमारी एक कंपनी
का डि फ्रक्स का हमारा गिट हब पेज है एंड
गिट हब हमारी प्रोफाइल है यहां पे यहां पे
आओगे तो एक रिपोजिटरी दिखेगी साइक्स नाम
से इसी तरीके से मान लो कोई एक हमारा क्या
है रिपोजिटरी ये हमारा सानिस टूल है इफ यू
वांट टू एक्सप्लोर यू कैन गो एंड
एक्सप्लोर दिस इज अ कंप्लीट अ बेसिकली अ
टूल फॉर बग बाउंट हंटर्स एंड वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल एंड हमारी खुद के
स्टूडेंट्स एंड टीम मेट्स ने मिलकर इसको
एज अ प्रोजेक्ट बनाया हुआ है एंड इसमें
फर्द अपडेट्स भी और भी आएंगी अगर आप
देखोगे इसकी तो आप देख सकते हो यहां पे कि
232 स्टेयर्स हो चुके स्टार्स हो चुके हैं
नाइन वाचिंग करेंटली फर 43 फॉक्स हो चुके
हैं सो अमेजिंग गोइंग दिस टूल तो इसी
तरीके से हमारा एक रिपोजिटरी है डि फ्रक्स
रेपो मान लो हमने इसी पे अपनी सर्विस
होस्ट की है जो भी सर्विस होस्ट की
है जो भी हमारी क्लाउड सर्विस है उसको
होस्ट की है ठीक
है अब इस जो होस्ट की है सर्विस ये एक
डोमेन डोमेन हमने उसको दे दिया जब भी हम
गिट पे जब तुम रिपोजिटरी क्रिएट करोगे तो
उसको एक डोमेन के तौर पर भी आप जैसे जैसे
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं हूं यहां पे ये
लॉगिन नहीं है ना ठीक है आप रिपोजिटरी जब
क्रिएट करोगे तो एक डोमेन भी आप उसको
असाइन कर सकते हो बेसिकली एक सब डोमेन आप
डोमेन सब डोमेन आप असाइन कर सकते हो तो
मैंने एक सब डोमेन असाइन कर दिया क्या .
github.io मैंने इनका एक सब डोमेन ही ले
लिया फ्री सब डोमेन मान लो d.g. i ये
असाइन कर दिया इस पर्टिकुलर प्रोजेक्ट को
इस पर्टिकुलर क्लाउड सर्विस को चलो और यह
वाली सी नेम रिकॉर्ड मैं क्या करूंगा अपने
होस्टिंग के डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड में डाल दूंगा
अब डायरेक्ट होस्टिंग के डालो या क्लाउड
फ्लेयर अगर यूज कर हो तो क्लाउड फ्लेयर
मैनेज करता है तुम्हारा फिर से डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड तो उसके में डाल दो जैसे मैंने
अभी टेक्निकल नेविगेटर का आप सबको दिखाया
रिकॉर्ड तो क्लाउड फ्लेयर मैनेज करी इसलिए
क्लाउड फ्लेर वाले में यहां पे डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड्स है अगर डायरेक्ट होस्टिंग
प्रोवाइडर आपका मैनेज करती है तो आपका
होस्टिंग जो है प्रोवाइडर वहां पे डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड आप वहां पे एंटर करोगे ठीक है तो
चलिए अब आपने डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड में सी नेम
एंट्री यहां पे कर दी अब इसका मतलब ये हुआ
कि जब भी कोई help.com को ओपन करेगा
ब्राउजर में यहां पे तो ये उस सर्विस को
फैच करेगा जो सर्विस गिट हब के इस
रिपोजिटरी पे होस्टेड है एंड यह वाले
यूआरएल के कंटेंट को होस्ट करेगा यानी कि
ये वा ये वाला जो हमारा यूआरएल का कंटेंट
है ये इसको फेच करेगा सर्विस को फैच करेगा
एंड उस सर्विस को आपको शोकेस करेगा बस
मतलब कहने का मतलब उसको फेच करेगा उसी
सर्विस को आपको दिखाएगा बस इसका मतलब
सिंपल यही होता है अब अब आती है मेन बात
अब आती है मेन पॉइंट मेन चीज कि भैया अब
इसमें सब डोमेन टेक ओवर का क्या रोल है अब
देखो मान लो आफ्टर फ ईयर
लेट्स सपोज आफ्टर फ इयर्स आई डोंट
नीड दिस आई डोंट नीड दिस डि फ्रक्स
रेपो क्लाउड सर्विस मान लो मुझे अब नहीं
चाहिए लेट्स सपोज आई डोंट नीड मुझे नहीं
चाहिए व्हाट आई विल डू आई
विल व्हाट आई विल डू अगर नहीं चाहिए तो
कोई भी चीज नहीं चाहिए तो क्या चा क्या
करना होता है हटा देना होता है फेक देना
होता है डिलीट मार देना होता है आई विल
डिलीट दिस
रेप यही
होगा मैं इस रेप को हटा दूंगा इस रेपो को
क्या करूंगा मैं हटा द इस सर्विस को मुझे
यूज नहीं करना इस सर्विस को हटा दू खत्म
यही करूंगा भाई मैं सिंपल सा फंडा है अब
यही होगा ना अब अब मैंने य सर्विस को तो
हटा दी भाई आई हैव रिमूव्ड दिस डिफ्रॉक
रेपो आई हैव रिमूव्ड मतलब मैंने यह सर्विस
यूज करना बंद कर दिया आई हैव रिमूव्ड बट
बट आई
फॉरगॉट टू
रिमूव द दैट सी नेम
एंट्री इन फ्रॉम माय डीएनएस
रेकॉर्ड फ्रॉम माय डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड ये गलती
हो गई मेरे से
एज अ जो भी तुम पोस्ट पे हो जिस चीज को
मैनेज अगर कर रहे हो इस पर्टिकुलर चीज को
उसने क्या किया कि यह वाली रिपोजिटरी का
यूज करना बंद कर दिया हटा दिया बट ये सीने
में एंट्री डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड से हटाना भूल
गया यह सबसे बड़ी गलती उस बंदे की और यही
आती है हमारी सब डोमेन टेकओवर की बात अब
क्या करेगा अ
हैकर कैन अ हैक हैक अ हैकर व्हेन फाइंड
दिस सब डोमेन कौन सा सब डोमेन भाई वही यही
हमारा हेल्प डिड कॉ फाइंड दिस सब
डोमेन फ्रॉम रेकन या सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन
न्यूमरेशन
एंड न ही विल विजिट ही विल विजिट दिस
डोमेन दिस सब
डोमेन ठीक है विजिट करेगा तो क्या होगा
क्या होगा भाई व्हेन ही विल विजिट दिस सब
डोमेन मैं यहां पे थोड़ा सा ऊपर कर देता
हूं
इसको ही विल गेट अ 404 एरर पेज 404 एरर
पेज
बाय
गिट बाय गिट क्यों क्योंकि सी नेम हमने
हटाया नहीं एंट्री भाई तो हमारा जो यूआरएल
है गिब वाला . गब आ इस पर अभी भी मैप तो
हो ही रहा है अभी भी हमारे डीएनएस के
अकॉर्डिंग एंट्री के अकॉर्डिंग अभी भी मैप
तो हो ही रही है तो जो भी बंदा help.com
को ओपन
करेगा वह ऑटोमेटिक इसको फेच करने की कोशिश
करेगा help.com और यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं है
क्योंकि डिलीट हो गई है तो 404 एरर पेज
गिट हब के तरफ से दे दिया जाएगा ठीक है अब
यह कैसा पेज दिखेगा आपको वो भी दिखा देता
हूं देख लो
404 गिट हब सब डोमेन टेक ओवर इसका मैं
एग्जांपल आपको दिखा देता हूं इमेजेस पर
चलते हैं एंड कुछ इस तरह का इमेज जो है
आपको एकदम से क्लियर कुछ इस तरह का इमेज
एकदम डिटो कुछ इस तरह का इमेज दिखेगा 404
फाइल नॉट फाउंड द साइट कंफिट दिस एड्रेस
डज नॉट कंटेन द रिक्वेस्टेड फाइल फाइल
नहीं है उसके पास रेपो नहीं है इफ दिस इज
योर साइट मेक श्यर दैट द फाइल नेम केस
मैचेस द यूआरएल द रूट यूआरएल डडडड
example.com यू मस्ट प्रोवाइड एन इक्सड
html5 रीड द फुल डॉक्यूमेंटेशन ये आ गई
बात अब जब ऐसा पेज आया तो जो हमारे बग
हंटर हैं जो हमारे रिसर्चर हैं उनके दिमाग
की बत्ती जल जाएगी अरे वाओ क्या रिजल्ट
मिला हमें तो इसीलिए सबसे ज्यादा यूजफुल
अगर 404 पेज है कहीं वो सब डोमेन टेकओवर
में ही है यकीन मानो 404 को कोई नहीं
देखना चाहता
एरर नॉट फाउंड एरर नॉट फाउंड अरे भाई गोली
मारो है ही नहीं रिसोर्स तो क्या करें
लेकिन सब डोमन टेकओवर के मैटर में 40 च का
बहुत ज्यादा रोल है भाई उसके अलावा कुछ और
चाहिए भी नहीं तो जैसे ही उसको 40 च मिला
द
हैकर
विल हैकर विल ट्राई टू टेक ओवर द सब
डोमेन बाय बाय
क्रिएटिंग द सेम सब डोमेन एट दैट क्लाउड
सर्विस प्रोवाइडर एंड
अपलोडिंग अपलोडिंग अ सिंपल इंक्स ड
html5 अरे सॉरी फाइल बस
सिंपल समझ में आ रहा समझ में आ गया बता
रहा हूं अभी आ रहा हूं उस पर भी आ रहा हूं
इतना समझ में आ गया भाई
इतना तो क्लियर हो गया बहुत इजी था यह समझ
में आया कि अब जब 404 आ जाएगा तो हैकर
क्या करेगा सब डोमेन टेक ओवर ट्राई करेगा
कोशिश करेगा सेम सब डोमेन को क्रिएट करके
उस क्लाउड सर्विस पे एंड एक इक्सड एटील
फाइल अपलोड करके लेकिन वो कैसे करेगा वो
भी मैं बताऊंगा कि क्या उसका प्रोसेस क्या
है वो भी बताऊंगा तो इतना तो समझ में आया
ना पहले यह बता
दीजिए गॉट इट बहुत सिंपली समझा रहा हूं
मैं बहुत आराम आराम से समझा रहा हूं भाई
इतना आराम से ना कोई नहीं समझाता याद
रखिएगा सीधा आएगा ये वो होता है फलाना
ठिकाना टूल यूज कर लिया खत्म कहानी वही
होता है सिंपली यही होता है जनरली मैंने
देखा है मैंने ट्रेनिंग के फील्ड में देखा
है टीचिंग के फील्ड में देखा है मैं सा
साल से ज्यादा हूं ज्यादा से इस फील्ड में
हूं ट्रेनिंग वाले में इवन मैंने कॉलेज
लाइफ से ट्रेनिंग स्टार्ट कर दी थी एक तरह
से देखा जाए तो तो मुझे आईडिया लग चुका है
मार्केट में क्या होता है मार्केट में
बेवकूफ बना रहे हैं लोग आजकल कुछ भी कुछ
भी बता देते हैं टू ल दो चार समझा देते हो
गया भाई खत्म हो गई नहीं कांसेप्ट तो
कांसेप्ट कहां गया कांसेप्ट मतलब कांसेप्ट
मैं सिखाऊंगा आके भाई कांसेप्ट तो बताओ
यार मार्केट में ज तुम कोई चीज बता रहे हो
कोई टॉपिक बता रहे हो कांसेप्ट तो बताओ
कांसेप्ट कौन बताएगा अलग से पैसे देक
बताएगा क्या कोई सीखेगा क्या कोई हद
है ठीक
है ओके थैंक यू श्रीकांत थैंक यू सो मच
श्रीकांत हाउ टू फाइंड सुब्रमण्यन
सुब्रमण्यम को कैसे फाइंड कर भाई बताइए
इनको सुनील कुमार को टाइपो है इनका टाइपो
इन्होंने किया है सब डोमेन होगा भाई पहले
की क्लासेस देखिए सब डोमेन फाइंड करने का
पता चल जाएगा देखो कोई मेरे को पूछ रहा है
ना
कि हाउ टू फाइंड सब डोमेन अगर कोई पूछ रहा
है ना तो मेरे को बहुत गुस्सा आ जाएगा याद
रखिएगा यह क्वेश्चन नहीं पूछ सकते तुम
जाके वीडियोस देखो बग बांटी के सारे सब
डोमन फाइंड करने के अलग से वीडियोस है भाई
क्या बोल रहे हो
यार
चलिए ओवरऑल एक शॉर्ट शॉर्ट समरी दे देता
हूं सिंपल सी चीज है सिंपल सब डोमेन
टेकओवर में एक डोमेन है उसका एक सब डोमेन
है ठीक है यह सब डोमेन की एक सर्विस होस्ट
हो रही है किसी भी क्लाउड सर्विस पे मैं
सिर्फ गिट हब का एग्जांपल अभी ले रहा हूं
आपका वो
google2 है एंड एक आपके वेबसाइट के डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड में ये सिनेम एंट्री है यहां पे
क्या सिनेम एंट्री है help.com जो है ये
किस पे मैप है ये मैप है आपके . github.io
जो कि एक सब डोमेन है जो कि रिलेटेड है इस
डेनिक्स रेपो रिपोजिटरी से जिसमें हमारी
सर्विस है कुछ सालों के बाद मुझे यह
सर्विस नहीं चाहिए यूज नहीं करना है बेकार
है हटा दिया अब ये सर्विस को यूज नहीं कर
रही है कंपनी डेनिक्स इज नॉट यूजिंग दिस
पर्टिकुलर सर्विस गॉट इट बस कुछ सालों के
बाद ऐसा होता है मान लो तो जब कुछ सालों
के बाद ऐसा होगा तो क्या होगा ये
रिपोजिटरी हट जाएगा बट बट गलती से मेरे
दिमाग से निकल निल गया कि सी नेम रिकॉर्ड
भी हटाना है डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड से यानी कि यह
जो सी नेम रिकॉर्ड है यहां पे यह सी नेम
रिकॉर्ड यहां पे वो यहां से एडिट करके
यहां से इसको डिलीट करना पड़ेगा ये मैं
भूल गया करना गलती से भूल गया अब जब मैं
भूल गया तो बाय चांस 4 साल 5 साल बाद 2
साल बाद मान लो या कभी भी ये भूल चुका हूं
मैं एक अटैकर मेरे सब डोमेन को इमेरेट कर
रहा है मेरे f.com के सब डोमस को इनमेट कर
रहा है तो उसको एक सब डोमेन मिला help.com
जिसका स्टेटस शो कर रहा है 404 कैसे शो
करेगा बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस है फजिंग के थ्रू
आप कर सकते हो डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
में आप स्टेटस कोड्स वाला लगा सकते हो
मैचिंग वाला उससे आपको निकल के आ जाएगा
ठीक है ना यह शो करता है वो इस पेज प जब
जाता है तो जैसे ही इस पेज प जाता है उसको
कुछ इस तरह का पेज दिखने को आता है कि
भैया 404 नॉट फाउंड और वहीं पर वो खुश हो
जाता है उसके बाद अब वो बंदा क्या करेगा
भैया वो बंदा वो बंदा हमारा गिट हब पे
जाएगा हम मैं आपको दिखाता हूं कैसे करेगा
वो इसके लिए मुझे गिट में लॉग इन करना
पड़ेगा एंड उसकी लॉगइन डिटेल्स
मुझे याद तो नहीं आ रही है बट मैं ट्राई
करता हूं एक मेरे पास लॉगिन है लेट मी
सी इट द सेम सो यहां पर ईमेल आईडी क्या
होगी मुझे नहीं याद आ रही है मुझे ईमेल
आईडी बट ईमेल आईडी मैं देख लेता हूं
शायद शायद यही है ईमेल आईडी
पासवर्ड में क्या है
भाई ठीक है पासवर्ड तो यह डाल दिया एंड आई
डोंट नो ईमेल आईडी कौन सी है ईमेल
आईडी यह वाली नहीं है क्या ठीक है टीम
फोनिक्स
gmail.com नाउ यह वाला ट्राई करता
हूं आराम से पेशेंस रखिए मजा आएगा अभी अभी
बहुत कुछ आएगा यह भी गलत है भाई क्या डाला
था यार
यूजर नेम क्या था यूजर नेम इसका तो शायद
हमारा यूजर नेम था
ना एक बार यूजर नेम देख लेता हूं मैं इसका
यूजर नेम आ जाएगा ना साइबो निक्स यहां से
शायद आ जाएगा ना शायद है ना लेट्स
सी
आई थिंक हमारा यूजर नेम था टीम डि फोनिक्स
य तो प देख लेते एक
बार देख लेते हैं टीम
फोनिक्स मुझे याद नहीं आ रहा यार मुझे
बिल्कुल भी याद नहीं आ रहा मैं एक बार
अपनी ईमेल आईडी डालता
हूं ईमेल
आईडी
मुझे लगता है डेवलपर्स ने चेंज किया शायद
ठीक है आई थिंक सो डेवलपर्स ने कुछ चेंज
किए हैं मुझे जहां तक लग रहा है इसलिए
यह नहीं हो रहा लगन राइट तो काम करते हैं
रहने देते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है लेट मी चेक वंस एक बार
मैं चेक कर लेता हूं रुक जाओ सभी लोग एक
बार मैं एक बार और चेक कर लेता हूं यहां
पर टीम टीम साइरोनिक्स
लेट्स सी की किसम है
यह कहीं तो मिलेगा
भाई यस सो दिस वन
इज कहां पर आई है मुझे यह मटन सॉल्यूशन
ओके इसी पे है ये मट सलूशन प है बट आई एम
नॉट गेटिंग द पासवर्ड तो फॉरगेट पासवर्ड
करता हूं
एंड टक्स वन
सॉल्यूशन ए
gmail.com यहां चलते हैं वेरीफाई कर लेते
हैं ये क्या है यूज द एरो टूल रोटेट द
ऑब्जेक्ट टू फेस इन द डायरेक्शन ऑफ द हैंड
हैं ये लो भाई इसमें क्या है सबमिट करो
कौन सी बड़ी बात थी चलिए अ लेट्स स्टार्ट
सेंड पासवर्ड रिसेट एमेल पासवर्ड रिसेट
ईमेल चला जा चुका है होप फुली आई हैव गॉट
यस मुझे मिल चुका है भैया तो अच्छी बात है
य कहां से ठीक है मैं पासवर्ड रिसेट एक
बार कर लेता हूं फिर मुझे डेवलपर्स को
देना पड़ेगा यह पासवर्ड ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं दे देंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
उन्होंने शायद रिसेट भी मारा हुआ है मेरे
ख्याल से लगता है चलो तो यहां पे मैं
पासवर्ड टाइप कर देता
हूं क्या पासवर्ड
टा
ओके चलिए मैं पासवर्ड यहां पर बना रहा हूं
जस्ट
वेट चलिए पासवर्ड बन
गया
ओके पासवर्ड मैं क्रिएट कर रहा हूं गाइस
जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट आई एम जस्ट क्रिएटिंग द
पासवर्ड न्यू पासवर्ड सेट सक्सेसफुली चलिए
पासवर्ड सेट हो चुका है अब वी कैन लॉग
इन सॉरी ओके सॉरी गाइस नाउ वी कैन लॉग इन
हियर एंड अब जो है
आपको ग्रेट
ग्रेट ठीक है चलो बढ़िया है बढ़िया है
बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया
सॉरी चलिए अब मैं आपको लॉग इन करता हूं
यहां पे दिखा देता हूं टक्स वन
सॉल्यूशन @
gmail.com ठीक है एंड यहां पासवर्ड डाल
देते
हैं पासवर्ड यहां डाल दिया होप फुली लॉगिन
हो जाएगा हो जा हो जा हो जा चलिए ये
वेरिफिकेशन कोड किस पे गया अच्छा इस पे
गया क्या अरे यार वेरिफिकेशन कोड भी है
क्या कुछ कहां है कोड
बट चलिए वेरिफिकेशन कोड भी डाल
दिया इनेबल टू एफ रिमाइंड मी टुमारो
टुमारो आ जाना भाई आज तो कुछ भी नहीं चलिए
तो ये जो है ना ये कुछ चीजें हैं मैं यहां
पे फिलहाल के लिए इस पे आ जाता हूं एंड
लेट्स लेट्स गो हियर अब यहां पे ये आपका
गिट ह पेज ओपन हो चुका है ठीक है मान लो
दिस गिट पेज है हैज बीन ओपन राइट एंड
प्लीज डोंट अ अ डोंट डू एनी पेन टेस्टिंग
ऑन आवर रिपोजिटरी बिकॉज़ ये टेस्टिंग फेज
में ही चलता रहता है हमेशा कुछ ना कुछ
होता रहता है तो प्लीज टेस्ट मत कीजिएगा
उसके लिए आपको कोई भी रिवॉर्ड बाउंट नहीं
मिलेगी फिलहाल क्योंकि मैं ओपनली सब कुछ
दिखा देता हूं आपको ठीक है बाद में हम सब
चेंज कर लेंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है बट
स्टिल अभी के लिए देख लीजिए अब ये क्या
होता है जैसे अब हैकर जो होता है ना वो
क्या करेगा भैया वो हैकर भैया वो क्या
करेगा लाइक व्हाट द हैकर विल डू पहले ये
समझते हैं कि इसको सब डोमेन टेक ओवर करने
के लिए पहले इस सिनेरियो को समझते हैं ठीक
है चलिए अब यहां पे तो भैया हैकर विल
ट्राई टू टेक ओवर द सब डोमेन बाय
क्रिएटिंग द सेम सब डोमेन एट द क्लाउड
सर्विस जैसे कोई भी क्लाउड सर्विस है चाहे
वो गिट हब अन क्लाउड फ्रंट हो या फिर आपका
फास्टली हो नेटलिफाई हो व्हाट एवर आप उस
परे जाके उस सर्विस के लिए एक सर्विस
क्रिएट करके सेम सब डोमेन को वहां डाल के
एंड आप उस सब डोमेन को टेक ओवर कर सकते हो
अगर वो अलाउ कर रहा है तो यानी हो पा पा
रहा है तो अब देखिए जैसे कि यह गब है गब
का मुझे मिला है मैं यहां पे क्या करूंगा
यहां पे ये मेरी प्रोफाइल है ठीक है अब
मुझे मान लो यहां पे प्लस वाले आइकन पे
जाऊंगा एक न्यू रिपोजिटरी क्लिक क्रिएट
करनी है मुझे तो मैं न्यू रिपोजिटरी
क्रिएट करूंगा मान लो ठीक
है अब यहां पे मैं रिपोजिटरी नाम दे दूंगा
जैसे help.com है तो मैं यहां पे कुछ भी
दे दूंगा
हेल्प डि फ्रक्स मैंने ये रिपोजिटरी एक दे
दिया ठीक है यहां डिस्क्रिप्शन में कुछ
देना है दीजिए मत देना है मत दीजिए कोई
दिक्कत नहीं यहां पे आप पब्लिक रहने दीजिए
यहां पे आप सिंपली ऐड गेट इनो फाइल अगर
करना है तो कीजिए कोई बात नहीं
rm3 जैसे ही क्रिएट करेंगे हमारा
रिपोजिटरी कुछ इस तरीके से क्रिएट हो
जाएगा हेल्प फोनिक्स जॉ हो गया अब अब क्या
करना है अब यहां पर सिंपल एक सबसे पहले
फाइल अपलोड कर देनी है इंडेक्स ड एटीएमएल
की कैसी फाइल होगी भाई वो सिंपल सी फाइल
होगी भाई और कुछ भी नहीं होगी जैसे मैं एक
सिंपल सा फाइल क्रिएट कर देता
हूं व्ट
हैपेंड
चलिए मैं यहां पर एक सिंपल सा फाइल क्रिएट
कर देता
हूं लैंग्वेज में हम क्या कर लेते हैं
एचटीएमएल यूज कर लेते हैं ठीक है एंड यहां
पे मैं सिंपल सा एक एचटीएमएल फाइल एक
एचटीएमएल कोड क्रिएट कर देता हूं एंड
लेट्स लेट्स
लेट्स टक टक ट यहां पर मैंने एक एचटीएमएल
कोड क्रिएट कर दिया एंड यहां पर मैं सिंपल
सा कुछ नहीं कर रहा मैं ना तो बॉडी टैग
यूज कर रहा हूं कुछ भी नहीं यूज कर रहा
हूं मैं सीधा एक दे देता हूं यहां
पर
मार्क्यू ओके मार्क्यू यहां पर देते
हैं
हेलो सॉरी सॉरी
हेलो वेलकम
टू हेलो दिस सब
डोमेन इज इज टेकन ओवर बाय
डिफ्रॉक्ड
सा हमने सिंपल सा क्या किया भैया हमने
यहां पे एक एचटीएमएल टाइप कर दिया एक
एटीएमएल लिख दिया एंड यहां पे हमने क्या
किया इसको क्या किया सेव कर दिया किस नाम
से सेव कर दिया सेव एस कर देते हैं एंड
इसको कर देते हैं हम डेस्कटॉप पे ही सेव
कर देते हैं डेस्कटॉप पे एंड index.htm
फाइल यहां यहां पे हमने इसको बना दिया
इक्ड
html.erb तो कुछ इस तरीके से दिखेगी एंड
ये आपको इस तरीके से जो एचटीएमएल है ये
चलता रहेगा हेलो दिस सब डोमेन इज टेकन ओवर
बाय रोनिक्स यहां पे अभी कोई मैं एचटीएमएल
हम लोग नहीं कर रहे हैं कि h1 और h2 टैग
यूज किया या टाइटल यूज करें या बॉडी यूज
करें ये सब नहीं कर रहे हैं हम बस एक
सिंपल सा एचटीएमएल पेज बना रहे हैं जहां
पे हमने हेलो दिस सब डोमेन इज टेक ऑन ओवर
बाय डिफ ये एक पीओ बना दिया हम ने बस बात
खत्म अब हम जो हमारा गिट हब रिपोजिटरी है
यहां पे वो फाइल को ऐड कर देंगे क्रिएट
न्यू फाइल नहीं करेंगे यहां पे क्रिएट
न्यू फाइल करके भी आप को कोड कर सकते हो
अपलोड फाइल पे क्लिक कर लीजिएगा यहां पे
यहां पे हम चूज कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पे
हमारी डेस्कटॉप पे जो फाइल है कहां गई
फाइल index.htm
फाइल यह रही यह फाइल को हमने सेलेक्ट कर
लिया एंड यहां पे यहां पे हमने सेलेक्ट कर
दिया एंड यहां पे हम कमिट कर देते हैं
जैसे ही हम कमिट करेंगे हमारी फाइल इस
रिपोजिटरी में जो है वो अपलोड होके आ
जाएगी
दैट्ची क्लियर कर देगा अब यहां पे क्या
करना है गाइज अब अब अब क्या करना है देखिए
जब आपने ये सारा काम कर लिया तो अब आपको
यहां पे एक सेटिंग का ऑप्शन दिखेगा हैकर
को हैकर सेटिंग वाले ऑप्शन पे आएगा ठीक है
सेटिंग वाले ऑप्शन पे आएगा यहां देखिएगा
डिक्स नेम जो है रिपोजिटरी का नक्स हेल्प
डेफॉक्स है ठीक है यहां पे नीचे आ जाइएगा
डिफॉल्ट ब्रांच जो है ना ये डिफॉल्ट
ब्रांच यहां पे मेन आपका लिखा हुआ है
बढ़िया कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है उसके
बाद नीचे आएगा यहां पे नीचे आएगा और भी
कुछ है और भी कुछ है और भी कुछ है यार कुछ
भी नहीं है और कुछ भी है कुछ भी नहीं है
कुछ भी नहीं है यहां पे अलाउ कमिट चेंजेज
है डिफॉल्ट मैसेजेस करके आ रहा है ठीक है
कोई बात नहीं और कुछ है और कुछ है कुछ भी
नहीं है और कुछ भी है कुछ भी है कुछ भी
नहीं है और कुछ भी नहीं है यार अब क्या
करें चलिए कोई बात नहीं कोई टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अब इधर आएंगे
इधर आएंगे इधर लेफ्ट साइड में लेफ्ट साइड
में और यहां पे कुछ देखेंगे कुछ काम का है
क्या हमारे एक चीज दिख रही है पेजेस चलिए
पेजेस पे चलके देखते हैं ये देख देखिए
पेजेस पे हम आ गए अब पेजेस पे जैसे ही
आएंगे तो यहां पे
डिप्लॉयड हब एक्शन डिप्लॉयड ये सब चीजें आ
रही है हमें इसमें कोई कुछ नहीं करना है
ब्रांच में नन आ रहा है ब्रांच में आप मेन
चूज कर लीजिए जो आपका मेन ब्रांच है हमने
चूज कर लिया बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया कोई
दिक्कत नहीं अब यहां पे गाइस सिलेक्ट
फोल्डर तो सिलेक्ट फोल्डर यहां पे आ जा
रहा है तो हमने सिलेक्ट फोल्डर यहां पे
रूट किया है सही है अब देखो यहां पे क्या
है गिट अप पेजेस इज करेंटली डिसेबल्ड स्ले
द सोर्स बिलो टू इनेबल गिट पेजेस फॉर दिस
रिपोजिटरी अब यहां पे क्या है ना गाइस जो
गिट पेजेस होते थे पहले आराम से बन जाते
थे यहां पे आके एंड यहां पे आके आप डोमेन
वगैरह एंटर कर सकते थे एंड डोमेन आप एंटर
करेंगे एंड उसके बाद वो सब डोमेन
पर्टिकुलर जो भी सब डोमेन आप एंटर कर रहे
हैं वो सब डोमेन जो है यहां पे आप कंफिल
कर सकते थे अभी क्या है कि यहां पे कि
इन्होंने गिट पेजेस को करेंटली डिसेबल कर
दिया है एंड फिलहाल जो भी आपका यहां पे रू
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री आप पेजेस एक्सेस कर
पाते हैं सिंपल सी फंडा यही हो जाता है
ठीक है अब यहां पे जैसे ये देखिए कन्फर
करने का गिट हब पेज पे आप आएंगे तो यहां
पे गिट हब पेजेस का कन्फर करने का आपको आ
तो जाएगा लेकिन अब यहां पे क्या है ना गिट
हब के कुछ प्लांस हैं लाइक गिट हब पेजेस
के उस गिट पेजेस को थोड़ा सा लाइक कैसा कर
दिया ना कि पेड कर दिया मान लो देखो जैसे
विथ अ गिट हब एंटरप्राइज अकाउंट यू कैन
रिस्ट्रिक्ट्स टू योर गिट पेजेस साइट बाय
पब्लिशिंग इट प्राइवेटली प्राइवेट गिट पेज
ऐसे करके लर्न 30 डे ट्रायल ये सब कर सकते
हैं अब यहां पे कहने का मेरा सेंस है कि
बस एक सब डोमेन को यहां पे कंफिल कर देना
होगा
दैट्ची वाला
help.com इस सब डोमेन को पेज पे हम यहां
पे होस्ट कर देंगे एंड
दैट्ची है समझ में आ रहा है अगर यह
सक्सेसफुली होस्ट हो जाता है बिना किसी
एरर के बिना किसी वेरिफिकेशन के तो आपका व
सब डोमेन टेक ओवर सक्सेसफुल हो जाएगा एंड
यू विल बी सक्सेसफुली टेकिंग ओवर दैट
पर्टिकुलर
सबड ट्स इट यहां पे फिलहाल अभी इन्होंने
वो कर दिया है बस और कुछ नहीं यहां पे ड
एंड रूट फोल्डर इन्होंने वो करवा दिया है
बस इसलिए ये चीज आपको अभी यहां पे दिख
नहीं रही है बाकी सारा प्रोसेस सेम चीज
आपका इसी तरीके से हो जाता है बस
दैट्ची वो वेबसाइट होस्ट हो जाएगी तो वो
टेक ओवर लेकिन अगर नहीं हो रही है होस्ट
किसी वजह से कोई प्रॉब्लम आ रही है कोई
एरर आ जा रहा है कहीं पे आपको वेरिफिकेशन
करना है सी नेम जो एंट्री है उसकी
वेरिफिकेशन करनी है डीएनएस वेरिफिकेशन का
स्टेप डाल दिया गया है तो वो टेकओवर नहीं
होगा अब कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस हैं जिसको
टेकओवर किया जा सकता है कौन-कौन सी
वल्नरेबल है और कौन-कौन सी नहीं है यह भी
तो जानना जरूरी है इ इसी के लिए हमारे पास
एक गिट हब रिपोजिटरी है कैन
आई टेक ओवर x वाई ज यह गिट हब रिपोजिटरी
सब डोमेन टेकओवर के लिए बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है इसको आप बुकमार्क कर लीजिए
अपने याद कर लीजिए या जो भी कीजिए बिना
इसके कुछ नहीं हो पाएगा सीधी सी बात है तो
अब यह है कैन आई टेक ओवर डॉट कैन आई टेक
ओवर x वा ज जो कि जनरली अब अपडेट होती
रहती है लास्ट आप देख सकते हो फोर मंथ अगो
एंड इसमें क्या है देखो सारे सर्विसेस जो
क्लाउड सर्विस प्रोवाइड करती है एंड कौन
सी वल्नरेबल है कौन सी नहीं ये लिस्टेड है
एक तरह से सारे तो नहीं बोलूंगा लेकिन
मैक्सिमम जो है वो वल्नरेबल वल्नरेबल या
नॉट वल्नरेबल सर्विसेस यहां क्लाउड
सर्विसेस लिस्टेड है अब नीचे आ जाइए जैसे
अब देखिए यहां से स्टार्ट होती है हमारी
कहानी एडब्ल्यू एस इलास्टिक बिन स्टॉक
वल्नरेबल है
क्लियर वल्नरेबल एडब्ल्यू लोड बैलेंसर
वल्नरेबल नहीं है एड्स ए3 वल्नरेबल है
एक्विया नॉट वल्नरेबल एजाइल सीआर एम
वल्नरेबल है ए ए आई आर ई आर यू वल्नरेबल
है अमाई नॉट वल्नरेबल एनिमा वल्नरेबल बिट
बकेट वल्नरेबल ठीक है इसी तरीके से पूरा
लिस्ट है क्लाउड फ्रंट अब वल्नरेबल नहीं
है पहले वल्नरेबल
था डिजिटल ओसियन वल्नरेबल है याद रखिएगा
डिस्कोर्स वल्नरेबल है ड्रीम होस्ट
वल्नरेबल नहीं है फास्टली नॉट वल्नरेबल
फिड प्रेस नॉट वल्नरेबल यह सारी सर्विसेस
है क्लाउड की जिसके बारे में दिखाया गया
है कि कि वल्नरेबल है कि नहीं है अगर आपको
इन सर्विसेस के कहीं पर पेज मिलते हैं 404
वाले जो इन क्लाउड सर्विसेस पर होस्टेड है
जो वल्नरेबल है इसमें तो आपका गुड लक एंड
आपको बांटी मिल जाएगी आप सब डोमेन टेकओवर
बस एग्जीक्यूट करके दिखाएंगे आपको बांटी
मिल जाएगी
ट्स इट कुछ नहीं है उसम आराम से मिल
जाएगी ट्स इट ठीक है अब यहां पे आप जाएंगे
एड्स ए3 मान लो ये रहा इशू पे चलो द
स्पेसिफाइड बकेट डज नॉट एजिस्ट इसमें क्या
है देखो जैसे यह देखो क्या है हैकर वन का
रिपोर्ट चलो देख लेते हैं एक बार कुछ
लोगों ने जिन्होंने फाइंड किया है s3 का
सब डोमेटिक हमने तो गिट अप पे देखा अभी s3
का भी देख लेते हैं ये देखो ये इन्होंने
एक कोई रिसर्चर है उन्होंने एक
वेबसाइट हमारी सब डोमेन है a2b आ ठीक है
अब जब a2b आओ को इन्होंने देखा तो यह किसी
पर्टिकुलर चीज पे इसका सी नेम रिकॉर्ड चेक
किया कैसे चेक करेंगे जैसे यही मान लो यही
मेरे पास एक सब डोमेन है अब इसका सी नेम
रिकॉर्ड मैं कैसे चेक करूंगा बहुत सिंपल
है किसी भी डोमेन सब मतलब सब डोमेन का
डोमेन का सी नेम रिकॉर्ड चेक करना हो तो
आप अपने काली मशीन में आ जाइएगा ठीक है
मैं आपको अब बताता हूं सारा चीज गेम
समझाता ता हूं आपको काली मशीन में आ
जाइएगा टर्मिनल ओपन कर लीजिएगा एंड यहां
पे एक कमांड होती है डिग डी आईजी डिग इस
डिग कमांड का यूज कर लीजिएगा डिग एंड उसके
बाद जो भी सब डोमेन है वो सब डोमेन डाल
दीजिएगा या जो भी डोमेन डाल दीजिएगा और
एंटर कर दीजिएगा
दैट्ची रिजल्ट नहीं आए हैं अब मैं क्या
करता हूं मैं एक कोई सी नेम रिकॉर्ड कोई
और सब डोमेन का निकालता हूं जैसे कि मेरे
पास बहुत सारे सब डोमस हैं
tesla.svs नीचे आएंगे थोड़ा सा नीचे आएंगे
तो आपको यहां पे एक सी नेम एंट्री दिखेगी
यह देखिए सी नेम एंट्री अब ये सी नेम
एंट्री कहां पे देखिए अकाउट
tesla.svs सीम रिकॉर्ड में कोई ऐसी सर्विस
तो नहीं है जिस पर यह मैप हो रही है यह
वाली चीज आपको चेक करनी है मेन फंडा हमारा
यही है चलिए यह तो आपने चेक कर लिया चलो
बहुत बढ़िया तो अब यहां पे हम रिपोर्ट प
थे इन्होंने डिग किया उस टाइम में किया जब
इन्होंने रिपोर्ट किया था कब किया था 2016
में किया था चलिए अच्छी बात है तब यहां पे
जब इनको सी नेम की रिकॉर्ड की एंट्री मिली
यहां पे देखो सी नेम क्या है ये वेबसाइट
ईस्ट यूएस अन एडब्ल्यू एस इसपे रीडायरेक्ट
मैप्ड मिली तब यहां पे इन्होंने रिपोर्ट
तैयार किया भैया कि यहां पे आ रही है 404
देखो 404 एर वा सोन तो मैंने क्या किया
मैंने क्या किया बना लिया एक s3 पे आपको
एक पीओ बना लिया कैसे बना लिया यह s3 पैनल
पे जाइए बकेट क्रिएट किए एंड बकेट नेम को
सोर्स डोमेन नेम पे कर दीजिए जो भी डोमेन
है उस पे कर दीजिए नेक्स्ट मल्टीपल टाइम्स
फिनिश कीजिए क्रिएट ओपन द क्रिएटेडटेड
अपलोड कीजिए एंड सेलेक्ट द फाइल index.htm
फाइल अपलोड कर दीजिए परमिशन टैब में जाइए
एंड वहां पे आप उसको रीड एक्सेस दे दीजिए
एंड आफ्टर अपलोड चेंज मेटा डेटा प जाइए
मोर पे जाके एंड देन मेटा डेटा में कंटेंट
टाइप में जो है वो एटीएमएल वगैरह कर दीजिए
एंड ए टेक्स्ट एटीएमएल एंड उसके बाद
प्रॉपर्टीज प जाके स्टैटिक वेबसाइट
होस्टिंग में जाके एंड वहां पे सब डोमेन
को कंफिल कर दीजिए यह सिंपल सा फंडा इस
तरीके का कुछ है मान लो मान लो लेट्स सपोज
यह तो हमने सिंपल सा बकेट का बता दिया मान
लो हम एड्स पे चलते हैं लेट्स सी इज माय
लगड इन हियर यस तो चलिए मैं यहां पे एड
ओपन करता हूं एक बार ठीक है लेट्स ओपन
एए एड ओपन हो गया हमारा हम s3 वाले कंसोल
पे चलते हैं मान लो हम s3 अ अ टेकओवर की
बात कर रहे यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए यहां पे
कुछ बने हुए हैं यहां पे s3 में आएंगे तो
यहां पे कुछ बकेट्स बने हुए हैं ठीक है
इसको हम छेड़छाड़ नहीं करने वाले हैं यहां
पे हम सिंपल क्रिएट बकेट पे क्लिक कर
देंगे बकेट नेम में हम डाल देते हैं डिफो
हेल्प डिफो हेल्प जो हमारा सब डोमेन है
मान लो ठीक है दैट्ची बस इतना ही और कुछ
नहीं हो गया उसके बाद यहां पे एसीएस को हम
डिसेबल ही करके रख देते हैं नीचे आ जाते
हैं यहां पब्लिक एक्सेस इनेबल डिसेबल का
है यहां पे हम बाद में डिसेबल इनेबल कर
देंगे बाकी कुछ नहीं करना है यहां पे सब
कुछ यहां पे सब कुछ देख लेंगे सारा कुछ
बहुत बढ़िया सब कुछ क्रिएट बकेट प क्लिक
कर
देंगे ठीक है बकेट हमारा क्रिएट हो गया
कहां गया भैया क्रिएटेडटेड तो हमारा
क्रिएटेडटेड ये रहा डि फोनिक्स हेल्प ये
जो अभी हमने बनाया इसको अभी पब्लिक एक्सेस
नहीं है तो हम क्या करेंगे डिफ्रॉक सेल प
क्लिक कर देंगे आगे डिफ सेल्प पे यहां पर
अब परमिश में चलते हैं परमिश में आएंगे तो
यहां पर बकेट पॉलिसी को जब आप एडिट करोगे
तो यहां पर बकेट पॉलिसी वगैरह आप चेंजेज
कर सकते हो जो भी चेंस करना है आप कर सकते
हो फिलहाल के लिए यहां पर सिंपल सा परमिशन
में आएंगे यहां पर आपको दिख रहा है कि
बकेट यह देखिए बकेट एंड ऑब्जेक्ट्स आर नॉट
पब्लिक तो यहां पर एडिट पर क्लिक करते हैं
एक बार एंड यहां पर सिंपल ब्लॉक को ह देते
हैं ब्लॉक ऑल पब्लिक एक्सेस को एंड यहां
पे क्या कर देते हैं सेव चेंजेज कर देते
हैं यहां पे कर देते हैं कंफर्म एंड यहां
पे कर देते हैं कंफर्म कंफर्म हो गया अब
यहां पे ये पब्लिक हो जानी चाहिए
ऑब्जेक्ट्स पे चलते हैं यहां पे बकेट्स पे
एंड अब देखते हैं क्या हाल है इस बकेट का
रीलोड करते हैं डि फ्रक्स हेल्प पे
एंड जस्ट वेट ऑब्जेक्ट्स कैन बी पब्लिक
यहां पे आ रहा है चलिए बढ़िया चीज है अब
यहां पे आते हैं प्रॉपर्टीज पे चलते हैं
यहां पे प्रॉपर्टीज पे एंड प्रॉपर्टीज पे
आएंगे तो यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आते हैं
नीचे की तरफ आते हैं नीचे की तरफ आते हैं
नीचे की तरफ आते हैं नीचे थोड़ा आ जाओ
नीचे आ जाओ आ जाओ आ जाओ आ जाओ एंड यहां पे
स्टैटिक वेबसाइट होस्टिंग का एक ऑप्शन
आपको दिख रहा है स्टैटिक वेबसाइट होस्टिंग
पे एडिट करेंगे यहां पे आपको इनेबल कर
देना है सिंपल एंड यहां पे आ रहा है होस्ट
अ स्टैटिक वेबसाइट ठीक है होस्ट स्टैटिक
वेबसाइट बस सिंपल अब यहां पे इन इंडेक्स
डॉक्यूमेंट यानी इक्सड html5 जो है लाइक
उसका नाम क्या है तो मेरा नाम वही है भाई
इक्ड
रीडायरेक्ट करना है कोई वेबसाइट प तो आप
यहां पर रीडायरेक्ट करके एंड यहां पर सब
डोमेन भी एंटर कर सकते
हैं ठीक
है
सिंपल यह सब डोमेन एंटर कर सकते हैं अब
यहां पर कोई भी सब डोमेन जैसे मेरा क्या
सब डोमेन था हेल्प
डिक्ड कॉ यह मैंने कर दिया प्रोटोकॉल
एटीपीएस यूज कर लेंगे एंड यहां पे हम यहां
पर सेव कर
देंगे फाइल को हम यहां पे अपलोड फाइल को
क्या करेंगे हम अपलोड कर देंगे कहां पे
अपलोड करेंगे यह देखिए द आप कोई भी ई
परमिशन टाइम में जाके पब्लिक एक्सेस दे
दीजिए जो भी आपका फाइल है यहां पे
index.htm का इसको हम अपलोड कर देंगे इस
बकेट के अंदर में इस बकेट के अंदर में
क्या करेंगे फिलहाल के लिए यहां पे बकेट
में जो हमारा बकेट बना है डेनिक्स हेल्प
इसमें आके यहां पे अपलोड पे क्लिक करके
एंड यहां पे ऐड फाइल पे क्लिक करके एंड
इक्सड
यहां पे आपको जो भी डिटेल्स है वो डिटेल
दिखेगी परमिश में आ आइएगा तो परमिश आपने
सेट कर दी है प्रॉपर्टीज पे आप आ जाइएगा
तो यहां पे कुछ प्रॉपर्टीज स्टोरेज क्लास
वगैरह ये सब दिखेंगी एंड यहां पे कुछ
इंक्रिप्शन का दिखेगा यहां पे चेक्सम
दिखेंगे एडिशनल एंड यहां पे मेटा डेटा
आएगा मेटा डेटा पे आ जाएंगे तो ऐड मेटा
डेटा करके यहां पे आप मेटा डेटा वगैरह कुछ
भी ऐड करना है वो मेटा डेटा आप ऐड कर सकते
हैं फिलहाल के लिए अपलोड कर दीजिएगा ठीक
है यहां पे मेटा डेटा को यहां रिमूव कर
देते हूं मैं अपलोड कर देता हूं ठीक है
यहां पे अपलोड आपकी हो जाएगी सिंपल उसके
बाद क्या करना है यहां पे जब आप अपलोड आ
जाएगी तो अब उस फाइल को सेलेक्ट कर लीजिए
जो सेले जो फाइल हमने दिया हुआ था हम यहां
पे अपलोड किया हुआ था और परमिशन में उसको
पब्लिक एक्सेस दे दीजिए एंड उसके बाद ऐड
मेटा डाटा क्लिक करके एंड कंटेंट को सेट
कर दीजिए जैसे हमने यहां पे क्या किया
क्लोज कर दिया यहां पे अब हमारा ये
index.htm फाइल है इस पे आ गए हम यहां पे
ये वाली आपको दिख रही होगी सारा डिटेल्स
सब कुछ यहां पे दिख रहा है यहां पे आ जाइए
परमिश के ऊपर में परमिश के ऊपर आएंगे तो
आपको अलग-अलग डिफरेंट डिफरेंट परमिश यहां
पे देखने को मिल जाएगा ठीक है अब यहां पे
आ जाते हैं यहां पे यहां पे वर्जन नंबर आ
जाएगा एंड यहां पे गाइस अब प्रॉपर्टीज पे
आप आ जाएंगे तो यहां पे आपको कुछ चीजें
दिखेंगी जो आपको यहां पे नीचे जाएंगे नीचे
आएंगे नीचे आएंगे नीचे आएंगे नीचे आएंगे
यहां पे तो आपको मेटा डेटा करके यहां पे
दिखेगा मेटा डेटा तो आप मेटा डेटा को एडिट
करके यहां पे कंटेंट टाइप टेक्स्ट
एचटीएमएल जो है ये चीज कर देंगे तो
टेक्स्ट एचटीएमएल ऑलरेडी आपका यहां पे दिख
रहा होगा कि यहां पे एक डेड है हमारा मेटा
डाटा दैट्ची एंड सेव चेंजेज कर देंगे t .
html5 फाइल के लिए index.htm के लिए
index.htm क्या है हमारा एक फाइल है सिंपल
सा जो कि यहां पे आप ओपन होके आप देख सकते
हैं चलिए तो हमने इसको यहां पर सेव कर
दिया अब क्या करना है भाई जब हमने चेंज
मेटा डाटा को इक्सड एकल कर दिया तो अब अब
अब इसको अगर आपने किया है यहां पे तो
वेबसाइट की तरह प्रॉपर्टीज प जाइए स्टैटिक
वेबसाइट प जाइए यूज दिस बकेट टू होस्ट
वेबसाइट प चले जाइए जो हमने काम अभी किया
था सिंपल सी चीज है यहां पे प्रॉपर्टीज प
चले जाते हैं पहले हम बकेट पे यहां
पे यहां पे चले जाते हैं एंड लेट्स
सी बकेट पे बकेट पे चले जाते हैं यहां पे
बकेट डिफ्रॉक सेल्प खोल लेते हैं यहां पे
यहां पे प्रॉपर्टीज पे चले जाते हैं सबसे
नीचे चले जाते हैं स्टैटिक वेबसाइट यहां
पे आपकी आ रही है अब वेबसाइट स्टैटिक
वेबसाइट में आप कर सकते हैं यहां पे एंड
अब यहां पे गाइस क्या कर सकते हैं आप
सिंपल होस्ट है स्टैटिक वेबसाइट कर सकते
हैं यहां पे एंड एरर ये डॉक्यूमेंट वगैरह
आप जो भी है यहां पे डायरेक्शन रूल्स
वगैरह लगा सकते हैं एरर डॉक्यूमेंट अगर
कुछ डालनी है डाल सकते हैं या तो अगर कोई
रीडायरेक्शन करनी है तो रीडायरेक्शन यहां
पे करके एंड यहां पे बकेट वेबसाइट एड्रेस
और पर्सनल डोमेन कोई सा भी आप डाल सकते
हैं तो बकेट वेबसाइट एड्रेस जो है आपका जो
भी बकेट की वेबसाइट एड्रेस है वो एड्रेस
भी आप यहां पे डाल सकते हैं जो भी आप
डालना चाहते हैं जो आपका एड्रेस है एंड
जैसे ही आप डाल देंगे सब कुछ आपका परफेक्ट
हो जाएगा सब कुछ आपका काम हो जाएगा जब सब
कुछ सक्सेसफुल हो जाएगा तो आपका वहां पे
स्टैटिक वेबसाइट जो है वो टेक ऑन आपकी जो
है वो आपका टेक ओवर हो जाएगा एंड
दैट्ची शॉट अगर ये चल रही होगी तो अभी
आपको दिख भी जाएगी ये देखिए जैसे यहां पे
ये आपको दिख रहा होगा ू st.com पीओ
html4 उस तरह का पेज तो आप वहां पे जाके
उस सर्विस को एक क्रिएट करके डोमेन को
कंफिल उस पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन को जो
अफेक्टेड है जो कि 404 दिखा रहा है एंड
वहां पे आप सब डोमेन टेक ओवर कर सकते हैं
अपनी एक index.htm फाइल अपलोड कर सकते हैं
एंड देयर यू विल जस्ट टेक ओवर दैट
पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन बस यहां पे कुछ परमिश
वगैरह सेट करना है कुछ स्टैटिक वेबसाइट
होस्ट कर देनी है आपको इसमें एडब्ल्यू एस
में गिट में गिट पेजेस बना देनी है वहां
पे थोड़ा सा प्रॉब्लम है बट वहां पे आप
पेजेस बना लेंगे अगर आपका आपके पास है तो
एंड आप फिर उसको कर पाएंगे सिंपल सी चीज
है यह आपको समझ में आ रहा
है चलिए अब मुझे बता द जल्दी से ये समझ
में आ रहा आप लोगों
को एवरीवन आपको समझ में आया क्या यहां पर
हुआ किस तरीके से हुआ जल्दी बताइए जल्दी
तब तक मैं यह वाला डिलीट कर देता हूं जो
बकेट है मेरा कोई फायदा नहीं है डिफ सेल्प
को रखने
का
मैं यहां पर डिलीट कर देता हूं ऑब्जेक्ट
को
पहले यहां क्लोज करते हैं एंड अब बकेट को
यहां से डिलीट मारते सिंपल सा फंडा है
डिलीट ए य कर देते हैं डिक्स हेल्प एंड
ट्स सॉ डिलीट दिस ठीक है चलिए ये बकेट
डिलीट हो गया हमारा ट्स इट एवरीवन गट
इट
हां अब सब डोमेन होस्ट करेंगे कि पेड करना
पड़ेगा कि नहीं देखो अब क्या होता है पेड
होना होगा कि नहीं होगा कुछ क्लाउड
सर्विसेस जो हैं जब आप उन परे सब डोमेन को
होस्ट करेंगे तो आपको हो सकता है वहां
पैसे देने
पड़े सब डोमेन वाला जो ये होस्टिंग करेंगे
तो वहां पे आपको पैसे देने पड़ेंगे तो
आपको वो पैसे दे सकते हैं बहुत मिनिमल
चार्ज लगता है टेस्ट करने के लिए अगर वो
सक्सेसफुल हो जाता है आपका सबमें टेक ओवर
तो जो कंपनी बाउंट पे करती है जनरली 99 पर
केस में वो आपको उस पर्टिकुलर जो आपने
पैसे पे किए वो बाउंट में ऐड करके ही आपको
पे करती है तो आपका वहां पर व पैसा भी
आपका रिफंड आ जाता है ठीक
है समझ में आ
गया जल्दी से बता दीजिए सभी लोग प्लीज
यहां रिप्लाई बहुत कम लोग देते हैं यार आप
लोग इतने लोग है बट रिप्लाई बहुत कम लोग
देते हैं इससे थोड़ा सा मजा नहीं आता
यार प्लीज बताइए और अगर आप लोगों का
इंटरेस्ट लूज हो रहा है बग बाउटी में
क्योंकि मैं देख रहा हू लाइव में बहुत कम
लोग आप रहे हैं मैंने देखा अभी बहुत कम
लोग है लाइव में तो क्या आप क्या चाहते हो
बताओ 10 तो क्लास हो चुके हैं क्या मैं
डिस्कंटेंट नहीं लग रहा है तो आई कैन डिस
कंटिन्यू हम नॉर्मल वीडियोस वगर लाएंगे
सीरीज को कंटिन्यू तो नहीं करेंगे लेकिन
अगर फायदा है तो कम से कम लाइव में आया
करो और जवाइन करो प्लीज यार इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक
है चलिए
चलिए
बढ़िया चलिए ठीक है तो इस तरीके से आप सब
डोमेन टेकओवर करते हैं राइट इस तरीके से
यू कैन टेक ओवर सबड अब यहां पर लिस्ट ऑफ
सर्विसेस यहां पे है यह सारी सर्विसेस जो
वल्नरेबल है आप देख सकते हैं इसके अलावा
पूरी डिटेल लिस्ट देखना है तो इश्यूज में
आइए आप कैन टेकओवर के इश्यूज में आ जाइए
इश्यूज में आएंगे यहां पे तो यहां प 26
नंबर इशू जो है उसमें सर्च करना है 26
सर्च करता हूं मैं यहां पे एंड यहां
पे
लेट्स
सी 26 में आई थिंक इनका डिटेल होना चाहिए
नहीं है ओके इश्यूज में चलते हैं क्लोज
में शायद चलते हैं शायद 26 नंबर पे तो था
ही शायद इनका कुछ था ना हां 26 नंबर क्लोज
में आएंगे तो यहां पे लिस्ट ऑफ स्पेसिफिक
सब डोमस सीन एज सी नेम्स ठीक है तो यहां
पे मैं चलता हूं
एंड यहां पे बहुत डिटेल लिस्ट जो है ना
आपको डिटेल लिस्ट व मिल जाती है वह सारे
सर्विसेस जो क्लाउड सर्विसेस प्रोवाइडर्स
हैं जिस पे अलग-अलग कंपनीज अपने सब डोमस
की सर्विसेस को होस्ट करती हैं एंड अगर इन
सर्विसेस की आपको लिस्ट मिल जाती है कहीं
पे मान लो कहीं पे सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन में
404 मिल जाती है या इन सर्विसेस की साथ
मिल जाती है तो आप इन पे ट्राई मार सकते
हो आप देख सकते हो यहां पे यह सारी
सर्विसेस की लिस्ट है टोटल ये सारे इतने
सर्विसेस है समझ में आ गया इन सबको भाई यह
सबको समझ में आ गया
भैया एवरीवन गट चलिए तो अब अब समझते अब
यहां पर बारी आती है गाइस नाउ इट्स टाइम
टू चेक फॉर सब्डोमेन टेक ओवर इट्स टाइम टू
चेक फॉर सब्डोमेन टेकओवर ठीक है कैसे हम
सब्डोमेन टेकओवर का हम चेक अप करते हैं
कैसे लुक अप करते हैं उसके लिए
प्रैक्टिकल्स की बारी आ गई अब एक तो मैंने
आपको डिग कमांड बताया जैसे यह वाला कमांड
चला दिया ए आपको सी नेम एंट्री मिल गई अब
इसमें आपको पर्टिकुलर सी नेम ही चाहिए तो
यह करके और सी नेम लिख दीजिए तो आपको
पर्टिकुलर सी नेम की जो इंक्वायरी है आपकी
हो जाएगी और सी नेम की रिजल्ट्स जो है
आपके सामने आ जाएगा ये सारे डिटेल्स चाहिए
तो एनी कर दीजिए एनी तो आपको जो भी
रिजल्ट्स है जितने डिटेल रिजल्ट्स है वो
सारे डिक कमांड आपको इस पर्टिकुलर सब
डोमेन के लिए देके रिजल्ट दे देगा मतलब दे
देना चाहिए तो सही देख लीजिए रिजल्ट अगर आ
जाता है तो अच्छी बात है लेट्स
वेट सर्विस नो सर्वर्स कुड बी रिच्ड ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं तो आप यह कमांड चला
लीजिएगा इसके अलावा यू कैन यूज एए लक अप
कमांड ये भी कमांड आपका वही कमांड है
बेसिकली डिटेल्स आपको प्रोवाइड करता है सो
यहां पे मैं अउ tesla.svs
बता दिया अब यहां पर टूल्स की बात करते
हैं प्रैक्टिकल्स की बात करते हैं कि किस
टूल से कैसे हम सबमें टेकओवर को फाइंड कर
सकते हैं सब डोमेन टेक ओवर फाइंड करने से
पहले मुझे बताइए आप लोग चैट में चलिए पहले
पूछूंगा मैं पहले सबसे सब डोमेन टेक ओवर
फाइंड करने से
पहले ठीक है कौन सी चीज की रिक्वायरमेंट
है आपके पास सबसे ज्यादा बताइए मुझे चैट
में सभी लोग बताइए प्लीज आंसर एवरी बडी
कौन सी चीज की रिक्वायरमेंट है सबसे
ज्यादा इफ यू आर गोइंग टू फाइंड सबमें वटी
सबसे ज्यादा आपके पास क्या होना चाहिए
बताइए चलिए
बताइए जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी फास्ट
फास्ट एंड्राइड पेलोड की यहां पर क्लास
नहीं हो रही है सॉरी फॉर दैट आई विल नॉट
बी आंसरिंग थैंक यू जो चीज हो रही है पहले
उस फोकस
करिए
सबसे ज्यादा किसकी जरूरत है बताइए सभी लोग
अगर रिप्लाई मुझे यहां पर 65 66 लोग हैं
अगर सब लोग रिप्लाई करेंगे तभी मैं कुछ
आगे बोलूंगा नहीं तो मैं सॉरी नहीं बोल
सकता मैं आगे फिर तभी कंटिन्यू करूंगा सभी
लोग अगर रिप्लाई करेंगे
तब ठीक है सब डोमस सब डोमेन सब डोमेन सब
डोमेन सब डोमेन
लिस्ट हां ठीक है सबसे ज्यादा
चाहिए सब डोमेंस हमें चाहिए
लॉट लॉट लॉट ऑफ सब डोम जितने सब डोमेंस
होंगे उतनी चांसेस है उसमें उतने 404
पेजेस होंगे एंड उतनी चांसेस होंगी कि
वहां सब डोमेन टेक ओवर प्रेजेंट है तो
हमारे पास एक सब डोमेन की लिस्ट चाहिए
भैया यह तो आपको पता ही है कैसे लिस्ट
निकालनी है सिंपल सा फंडा है सब फाइंडर
यूज कर
लो सब लिस्टर यूज कर
लो है ना ऑल्ट डीएनएस यूज कर लो सॉफ डोमेन
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग कर लो गो बस्टर यूज कर लो
सब डोमेन ब्रूट फोर्सिंग कर लो ये सारी
चीजें करो ना सब डोमेन ब्रूट फोर्सिंग गो
बस्टर से भी तुम कर सकते
हो है ना तो सारी चीजें यहां पे आप देखो
यहां पे यह देखो गो बस्टर आपके इसमें
प्रेजेंट है इसी में यहां पे ये चल रहा है
ये गोबस्टर आपका इसमें ये ऑलरेडी
इंक्लूडेड है आप इसको यूज कर
लो सारा ब्रूट फोर्स फ्रूट फोर्स करके सब
डोमेन को सॉर्ट करके यूनिक सब डोमस निकाल
के उसके बाद लाइव एसटीटीपी एक से प्रोब
करके फाइनल लिस्ट तैयार करो और फिर उस
लिस्ट का यूज करना है सब डोमन टेकओवर वन
लिमिटी फाइंड करने के लिए एंड ये कैसे
करेंगे तो इसके लिए हमारे पास बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल्स पड़े हुए हैं सभी सभी
सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग टूल्स पड़े हुए हैं और
सबसे ज्यादा पहले सबसे पहले हम कुछ टूल्स
को देखने वाले हैं देन हम लास्ट में एक
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग टूल देखेंगे जो सबसे
सबका गुरु है सबसे पहले हम जो टूल जिस टूल
को देखने वाले हैं उसका नाम है सब्जी जी
हां उस टूल का नाम है सब्जी यह मत सोचना
सब्जी कौन सी सब्जी ना ना ना ना वो वाली
सब्जी नहीं वो वाली जो तुम सोच रहे हो
सब्जी इस टूल का नाम है एस य बी जड वाई
सब्जी एंड गिट पे ये आपको मिल जाएगी
पेंटेस्ट पैड की तरफ से ये टूल एंड जब आप
इस पे आएंगे तो ये कुछ ज्यादा ही बड़ा है
इसको मैं छोटा छोटा छोटा कर लेता हूं एंड
यहां पे ये टूल आपको कुछ इस तरीके से
सब्जी जी मिल जाएंगे एंड सब्जी को सब
डोमेन टेकओवर टूल व्हिच वर्क्स बेस्ड ऑन
मशीन मैचिंग रिस्पांस फिंगरप्रिंट्स फ्रॉम
कैन आई टेक ओवर एक्सवा ज कैन आई टेक ओवर
एक्सवाई ज से ही यह फिंगरप्रिंट मैच करते
हैं एंड यह बताते हैं कि यह पर्टिकुलर
लिस्ट ऑफ सब डोमस वल्नरेबल है सब्डोमेन
टेकओवर के कि नहीं है सिंपल कैसे इंस्टॉल
करना है गो लैंग्वेज चाहिए गो यह वाला
कॉपी किया एंड यहां पेस्ट किया टर्मिनल
में यहां पेस्ट किया
एंड पेस्ट यह क्या खुल गया
भाई
यहां पर हमने क्या किया कॉपी किया गो
कमांड यहां हमने पेस्ट किया एंड एंटर किया
एंड हमारी इंस्टॉलेशन डन सब्जी की गो
कमांड की गो कमांड के थ्रू गो कमांड से
कोई भी टूल इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो एप्ट
इंस्टॉल गो लैंग पहले कर लीजिएगा गो लैंग
इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए नहीं होगा तो नहीं
होगा वो इंस्टॉलेशन गो से जो भी कमांड जो
भी टूल्स इंस्टॉल होती है वह कहां जाती है
भैया वो जाती है आपके होम
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री के होम
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
होगी और इसमें आपको दिख जाएगी इसमें आपको
सब्जी दिख रहा होगा हमारा अब ये सब्जी
ऑटोमेटिक ये एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा कहां पे
डायरेक्ट
सबज एंटर करेंगे एंड ये टूल आपका
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा आपको उस
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
का एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल हमने इसका पाथ सेट
कर रखा है तो हमारे इस z एसएचआरसी को पता
है शेल को कि भैया वहां जाके और जो भी गो
के टूल्स है वहां से डायरेक्टली एज अ
सिस्टम टूल या कमांड की तरह एग्जीक्यूट कर
देना है कैसे भैया तो आपको दिखा देता हूं
कैट स्ल रूट के अंदर मिलता है आपका डॉट z
ए एच आर स एंटर करेंगे तो लास्ट में आपको
ये पाथ दिख रही होगी एक्सपोर्ट पाथ इ
इक्वल टू पाथ रूट गो बिन यानी होम
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
होगी वह यहां पे ले लेने
का बस अब यहां पे पाथ इको अ एंड यहां पे
एक बार देख लेते हैं पाथ एंड य को जब पाथ
आप करेंगे तो आपको पूरी पाथ जो भी लिस्टेड
है वो पाथ आपको यहां पे दिख जाती है पाथ
में यूएसआर लोकल एस बिन यह भी पाथ है
यूएसआर लोकल बिन पाथ है यूएसआर बिन एस बिन
पाथ है यूएर अ बिन एस बिन पाथ है यहां पे
यूएसआर लोकल गेम पाथ है ये सारे पाथ हैं
यहां पे उसी तरीके से रूट गो और बन भी
आपका पाथ सेट है बस अब हम सब्जी को
एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे सब्जी हमें नहीं आती है
यूज़ करने हान देंगे और इसको यूज़ करेंगे
कैसे भैया अब इसमें चार ही कमांड दे रखे
हैं अपडेट वर्जन तो पहले हम अपडेट कर लेते
हैं सब्जी अपडेट चलिए सब्जी भाई अपडेट हो
जाइए सब्जी तो बिल्कुल अपडेटेड है अब
सब्जी का रन वाला वेरिएंट यूज़ करेंगे तो
सब्जी रन एंड देन हाई फन हाइफान हेल्प
करेंगे ताकि हमें इसकी हेल्प पता चल जाए
तो आप रन के साथ क्याक यूज कर सकते हैं तो
भैया देखिए यहां पे टारगेट एक पर्टिकुलर
डोमेन या लिस्ट ऑफ डोमेंस कॉमा दे देके तो
आप टारगेट हाइफ यूज कर सकते हान टारगेट्स
एक फाइल जिसमें सब डोमस है मेरे पास एक
फाइल पड़ी है कौन सी ला फल जिसमें ला के
बहुत सारे सब डोमस पड़े हैं चलिए इसी पर
हम फाइनल अपना इसको चलाने वाले हैं तो
क्या करेंगे
सबजी हो गया अब रन उसके बाद हाई फन हाई फन
टारगेट्स
एंड फाइल का यूआरएल तो फाइल का पाथ क्या
है भैया हमारा टेस्ला वाला फाइल है टेस्ला
फाल दे दिया हमने ट्स इट अब आपको कुछ और
इसमें लगाने है क्या टाइम आउट 10 सेकंड का
है इसको हम बढ़ा देते हैं हाई फन आई फन
टाइम आउट को 30 सेकंड कर देते हैं वेरीफाई
एसएसएल इफ सेट टू ट्रू इट वंट चेक साइट्स
विथ इनसिक्योर एसएसएल तो हमें ऐसा कुछ
नहीं करना भाई सबको टेस्ट करो सेव ओनली
वल्नरेबल सब डोमस हान हान वन लगा दोगे तो
नहीं हमें सब देखना है भाई सब दिखाओ बस
ट्स इट तो हो गया खत्म कहानी एंड इतना
करने के बाद हम एंटर करेंगे एंड अब हम वेट
करेंगे कि यह हमारे को रिजल्ट शो करेगा
कोई सब डोमेन वल्नरेबल है क्या देखिए नॉट
वल्नरेबल नॉट वल्नरेबल नॉट कोई भी
वल्नरेबल नहीं है नॉट वल्नरेबल नॉट
वल्नरेबल देख रहे हो ये स्कैनिंग कर रहा
है सारे सब डोमेंस की आर यू गाइज सीइंग
फीलिंग आ रही है हैकर वाली रिसर्चर वाली
सारे सब डोमेंस को ये स्कैन करेगा अगर कोई
वल्नरेबल सब डोमेन फाइंड कर देता है ये तो
उस पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन आप विजिट कीजिए
देखिएगा 404 पेज दिख रहा है कौन सी सर्विस
की दिख रही है वो सारा कुछ कीजिए एंड आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा ठीक है फिर उसके बाद आप
क्लेम कर सकते हैं यह देखो
अच्छा ओके ये देखो एक इसने वल्नरेबल शो
किया बट मुझे लगता है फॉल्स पॉजिटिव होगा
बट देख लेते
हैं एक यहां प वल्नरेबल आया हुआ
है चलो वल्नरेबल दिखा तो रहा है भले फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव हो जो भी
हो स्कैनिंग
करेंटली यह वल्नरेबल एक ये भी वल्नरेबल
अच्छा चलिए देखते
हैं ओके रिजल्ट्स आ रहे हैं आपके
सामने बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया क्या
बात है 75 लोग आ गए हैं कहां चले जा रहे
हो तुम लोग बीच-बीच में भग जा रहे हो क्या
अरे यार एक बार 100 प्लस आ जाओ जल्दी से
अभी लास्ट में इतना तो
करो देख रहे हो ये कर रहा है ये कर रहा है
नॉट वल्नरेबल नॉट वल्नरेबल नॉट वल्नरेबल
स्कैनिंग हो रही है
भाई वीपीएस क्लाउड पे जब स्कैन करोगे तो
यह और भी फास्ट स्कैन होगी याद रखिएगा और
भी फास्ट होगी बहुत फास्ट फट से हो जाएगा
क्योंकि बहुत ज्यादा सब डोमेंस थे नहीं
इसमें चलिए यहां पे कुछ-कुछ एचटीटीपी
एरर्स आ रहे है मतलब इससे ये कनेक्ट नहीं
कर पा रहा है पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन से
दैट्ची है तो तो इसको इग्नोर मारिए कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है चलिए हो गया ये अब यहां पे
ना इसने क्या किया गाइस कुछ दो मुझे
वल्नरेबल दिखाए एक तो ये दिखाया एक ऊपर भी
दिखाया है अब देखो वल्नरेबल क्या दिखा रहा
है कि ये सब डोमेन अनबाउंस पे है पहली बात
तो पहले तो हम चेक करेंगे कि अनबाउंस
हमारा लिस्ट में है कि नहीं वल्नरेबल वाला
तो यहां पे कैन आई टेक ओवर पे आ जाएंगे
नीचे आ जाएंगे लिस्ट में एंड यहां अनबाउंस
खोजें अनबाउंस अनबाउंस अनबाउंस अनबाउंस
अनबाउंस कहां है ये रहा अनबाउंस अब यहां
पे लिखा हुआ है नॉट वल्नरेबल नॉट वल्नरेबल
अब इसका यहां इशू है एक इस इशू पर जाएंगे
क्या होता है कई बार कि नॉट वल्नरेबल यहां
तो अपडेटेड है बट किसी रेयर केस में रेयर
केस रेयर इश्यूज में कभी-कभी इसको कई
रिसर्चस ने टेक ओवर कर लिया होता है मतलब
रिसेंट में वो टेक ओवर कर लेते हैं तो
सबसे ऊपर सबसे ओल्ड वाली आती है नीचे
जाएंगे तो सबसे लेटेस्ट इसकी अपडेट जो है
वो आएगी ये कौन है भाई अच्छा सबसे नीचे
आओगे तो यहां पे लेटेस्ट अपडेट के साथ
आएगी यहां पे एंड यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं
यहां
पे आ इट्स स्टिल वल्नरेबल बट ओनली एज अ
रेयर एज केस एक् आई एक्सप्लोइटेड अ वैलिड
वन अ फ्यू डेज एगो सी दिस चलिए देख लेते
हैं यहां पे सी दिस पे आते हैं यहां पे
एंड यहां पे लास्ट में क्या कर दिया है
अनबाउंस इज नॉट वल्नरेबल फॉर सब्डोमेन टेक
ओवर एंड इसको क्लोज कर दिया गया इसका मतलब
क्या है कि यह नहीं है वल्नरेबल बस सिंपल
सी चीज है यह किसी एज केस में हो सकता है
कभी-कभी बट जनरली ये वल्नरेबल नहीं है तो
बात तो पहले यहीं पर खत्म हो जाती है
दूसरी बात अब क्या आती है कि यह देखना कि
कि भैया ये जो पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन है ये
इसका सी नेम अनबाउंस पे रीडायरेक्ट कर भी
रहा है या इसका रिजल्ट क्या आ रहा है तो
हम इसको क्या करेंगे कॉपी कॉपी लिंक
एड्रेस कर लेते हैं है ना कॉपी कि लिया और
इसको हम एक वेबसाइट पे यहां पे पे डोमेन
सब इस सब डोमेन को ओपन करेंगे देखेंगे
व्हाट वी आर गेटिंग देखो जब हमने किया तो
यहां पे क्या आ रहा है नॉट फाउंड अरे बाप
रे 90 लोग आ गए क्या भाई सच में 90 आ गए
मतलब 100 प्लस कर दोगे क्या अभी 100 प्लस
हो जाएगा मतलब थोड़ी देर के लिए लिए भी कर
दो यार 100 प्लस मुझे भी तो मजा है 90
कैसे आ गए यार अचानक से ये 90
70 अरे भाई मतलब समझ में नहीं आ अभी तो 75
थे ये 90 हो गए एकदम से फिर 78 हो गए ये
क्या हो क्या रहा है ये एक बार 100 एक बार
100 पे आ जाओ ना यार 100 वाले बुला लो
सबको जितने भी हैं एक बार चलिए यहां नॉट
फाउंड आ रहा है यहां अनबाउंस का कोई पेज
नहीं आ रहा अनबाउंस का पेज आता तो क्या
होता है देखो अनबाउंस सब डोमेन टेक ओवर
कुछ इस तरह का पेज दिखना चाहिए था हमें
देन हमारे लिए बहुत खुश खुशी की बात हो
जाती
कुछ नहीं नहीं ये नहीं है प अन बाउंस
पेज जो गिट का
है अन
बाउस ये कुछ इस तरीके से इंप्रोपर्ली
अ कंफिट ऐसा कुछ करके कुछ भी मतलब मैसेज
आता है ये नॉट फाउंड तो नहीं आता तो आप
समझते हैं कि कुछ तो बात है यहां पे तो
पहली बात तो यहां पे कुछ पेज अनबाउंस का आ
भी नहीं रहा है दूसरी चीज हम इसको मैनुअली
भी वेरीफाई करेंगे ऐसे ही नहीं कि बस कई
बार कई टूल्स फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स भी देती है
भैया समझ में आ रहा है तो मैं क्या कर
देता हूं मैं इसको कॉपी तो किया ही है एक
नया टैब ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड यहां पे मैं
डिग कमांड से इसकी सी नेम को वेरीफाई करता
हूं डिग एंड जो हमारा अ कहां गया भाई सब
डोमेन है जो वल्नरेबल दिखा रहा था ये टूल
इससे पता भी चल जाएगा एंड यहां पे हमें
क्या चाहिए सी नेम एंट्री चाहिए
इसकी तो हमने सी नेम एंट्री किया एंड इसकी
सी नेम यहां पे देख सकते हो h कीनेट यहां
पे सिंपली ये अनबाउंस पे तो नहीं है
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है ये हमारा मैप नहीं
हुआ है इसका मतलब ये एक फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रिजल्ट भी है तो कई टूल्स जो होते हैं वो
आपको रिजल्ट्स तो देते हैं ठीक है ब कई
बार फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स देते हैं तो जो भी
रिजल्ट्स आपको आए उसको मैनुअली वेरीफाई
करना बहुत जरूरी है वो वेरीफाई कीजिए जब
आपको मैनुअली बिलीव हो जाए तभी आप भैया उस
चीज को आ आ बढ़ाइए उस चीज को आगे ट्राई
कीजिए तो यह आपने क्या यूज किया सब्जी टूल
यूज किया सिंपल सब डोमस की लिस्ट को पास
कीजिए एंड यहां पर कहानी खत्म अब इसी के
साथ एक टूल और है जिसका नाम है सब सब सब
सबसे रखते हैं सब जक सब जक गिट हब यह भी
एक टूल है चलिए अब इस टूल से देखते हैं एक
बार क्या
है सब्जेक्ट प आप आएंगे जब तो यहां पर
पब्लिक आर्काइव लिखा हुआ है यानी कि इसको
आर्काइव कर दिया गया है बाय द ओनर 7 जन
2024 को यह रीड ओनली है ओनली अब ऐसा क्यों
भैया हो सकता है यह काली के रोलिंग
रिपोजिटरी में आ चुका है यह तो हम देख
लेते हैं एट लिस्ट सब
जक एंड यह काली के रिपोजिटरी में काली
रोलिंग में ऑलरेडी इंक्लूड कर दिया गया
इसलिए वहां से पब्लिक आर्काइव कर दिया गया
है एंड अब यह काली में आप आराम से ए
इंस्टॉल सब
जक सब जैक करके इसको इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं
एंड ये आपका इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा उसके बाद
ओपन करना है सब जक न ए इसकी हेल्प फाइल आ
जाएगी एंड अब आप इस टूल को चला
पाएंगे 100 प्लस है बट
काम है यहां पे मुझे कुछ नहीं आता यूज़
करने टूल ल मैं तो भाई देख के यूज़ करूंगा
सिंपल सी चीज है मुझे कुछ नहीं आता आप भी
आप भी सोच लो आपको कुछ नहीं आता टूल यूज़
करने देख के करना है सिंपल ठीक है तो अब
यहां पे सब्जेक्ट किया अब यहां पे हान डब्
से पाथ ऑफ वर्ड लिस्ट ये वही मतलब है सब
डोमेन की लिस्ट वर्ड लिस्ट का यहां पे
इनका मतलब है सब डोमेन तो हमने यहां पे
किया
tesla.svs के लिए अगेन एंड हान t थ्रेड्स
तो हान t 100 कर देते हैं थ्रेड्स को नवी
से वर्वस मोड इनेबल कर देते हैं और एंटर
करते हैं जैसे एंटर करेंगे यह बहुत
ही फास्ट स्कैनिंग करेगा और आपको दिखा
देगा कि यह सारे सब डोमस वल्नरेबल है
इसमें से कोई या नहीं है तो इसने तो भाई
सब कुछ सही किया है और इसने दिखाया कि कोई
भी वल्नरेबल नहीं है जो कि करेक्ट है कोई
भी वल्नरेबल यहां पे आपका सब डोमेन नहीं
है अब जब ये लिस्ट बहुत बड़ी होगी ना तो
आपको और भी मजा आएगा चलता जाएगा चलता
जाएगा फटाफट होता जाएगा होता जाएगा एकदम
मतलब मस्त इंटरेस्टिंग वे में पूरा आपको
लिस्ट आपको दिखेगा ड ऐसे हो रहा है तो
आपके सामने वो लिस्ट में वल्नरेबल नॉट
वल्नरेबल सारा कुछ आ जाएगा ठीक
है धन्यवाद धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद थैंक
यू सर राइजन 555 य इनफ है यू है यहां पर
आपका यू है एच वाला ट्राई करो एक बार य एच
वाला जो है वो अगर मिल जाए तो ठीक है
सही है हा यू भी सही है सही है सही है कर
सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है चल जाएगा च यस
यस अनबाउंस इ नॉट वल्नरेबल
करेक्ट चलिए तो यह आपका किस तरीके से यह
आपका टूल है क्या सब्जेक्ट सब्जेक्ट को आप
इस तरीके से यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है इसके
अलावा देरर मल्टीपल टूल सब ओवर करके टूल
है आप उसको भी यूज कर सकते हो यह भी टूल
है एक सब
ओवर सब लेकिन इससे सबसे खतरनाक टूल जो है
व मैं अभी बताऊंगा वो अभी मैंने आपको
बताया नहीं है सबसे ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
टूल जो है सबसे बढ़िया सब ओवर ये काफी
पुराना टूल है काफी पुराना टूल है तो इफ
यू वांट यू कैन यूज आई विल नॉट रिकमेंड
दिस दिस प्रोजेक्ट इ डिस कंटिन्यूड नो मोर
अपडेट्स विल बी प्रोवाइडेड सॉरी समझ में आ
रहा है तो इन्होंने बोला कि ये कम वो हो
चुका है खत्म हो चुका है भैया तो अब इसको
छोड़ दीजिए तो इसको यूज करो ना करो आपकी
मर्जी है अब इसके बाद अब इसके बाद सबसे
इंटरेस्टिंग अच्छा एक चीज बताओ एक चीज मैं
और आपको एक तरीका बता देता हूं गाइस लेट
मी टेल यू अवे जस्ट वेट एक सेकंड वेट
कीजिए एक मेरे पास कोई
इंपॉर्टेंट कॉल आ रही है मैं इनको बोल
देता
हूं जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट हां जी चलिए हो गया हां तो मैं कहां
था कहां था मैं सब्जेक्ट क्या कर रहा था
मैं हां एक चीज मैं आपको बता देता हूं
यहां पे जैसे आपको मान लो एक एक टूल का
मैं और आपको थोड़ा सा आईडिया दे देता हूं
जैसे मान लो
tesla.svs
में है अलग-अलग मान लो टूल से हमने यूज़
किया है दो फाइल्स में ये सब डोमस की
लिस्ट है तो अब मान लो ला में कितने हैं
मान लो देखो tesla.svs
एकटी तो डल सफन एल कर देते हैं टोटल सब
डोमस कितने है दोनों फाइल्स में 1110
फाइल्स है ठीक है मतलब एंट्रीज है मुझे इन
दोनों को मिक्स कर देना है मान लो वी हैव
टू मिक्स दोस दोनों को एक फाइल में मिक्स
कर देना है अगर ऐसा कुछ करना हो तो आप अ
न्यू करके एक एट इंस्टॉल अ न्यू यह कर
लीजिएगा अच्छा अन्यू यहां पे शायद नहीं
मिलेगा अ न्यू आप टूल इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा
यहां प क्लोन यहां पर कर लीजिएगा अ न्यू
हब यह अच्छा टूल
है यह टॉम नॉम नॉम के तरफ से यहां परन तो
आप आ जाइएगा यहां प न्यू पे एंड यहां पर
आप सिंपली इसको गो इंस्टॉल वाला कमांड
कॉपी कर लीजिएगा एंड यहां पर इसको पेस्ट
कर दीजिएगा एंड अ न्यू जो है इट विल बी
इंस्टॉल्ड इन योर गो पाथ बाइनरी प इंस्टॉल
हो जाएगा उसके बाद आप क्या करेंगे सिंपल
कैट एंड यहां पर टेला फाइनल
एक्टी ये करेंगे टी
एक्टी यहां पे ये कर देंगे ठीक है ना मतलब
दो फाइल्स को मुझे कन्फर कंबाइन करना है
उसके बाद यहां पे एक ग्रिप यहां पे देंगे
यहां पे अ न्यू आप कमांड दे देंगे एंड
इसको एक फाइल में कर देते हैं फाइनल लिस्ट
डटी एकटी एंड इसको हम एंटर कर देंगे जब हम
एंटर कर देंगे तो यहां पे एक फाइल बन जानी
चाहिए एलएस करके आप देखेंगे फाल list.txt
अब इसके अंदर की जब आप एंट्रीज देखेंगे
कितने सब डोमस है तो आपको 100 110 ए
दिखेंगी यानी कि दो जो भी कमांड्स जो जो
भी दोनों के सब डोमस थे वो फाइनल लिस्ट
में यहां पे ये कंबाइन हो चुके हैं ठीक
है समझ में आ रही है ये चीज
आपको ये समझ में आ गया ये कंबाइनिंग आप
काम कर सकते
हैं ठीक है एवरीवन
गॉट एवरीवन गॉट जल्दी बताइए मैं देख रहा
हूं चैट आपकी चैट देख रहा हूं मैं फोन पे
चैट देखता हूं गाइस इसलिए आपको थोड़ा सा अ
दिखता होगा कि मैं इधर देख रहा हूं आपके
चलिए आई होप कि आपने समझ लिया होगा इस चीज
को ठीक है अब अब आते हैं सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग
टूल सबसे ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग एंड सबसे
ज्यादा अमेजिंग टूल पे एंड जो कि आप
सब्डोमेन टेकओवर को ऑटोमेट करने के लिए
सब्डोमेन टेकओवर के लिए आप यूज कर सकते
हैं एंड बहुत ही अपने आप में बहुत ही बहुत
ही शानदार टूल है इसको आप मल्टीपल चीजों
के लिए यूज़ कर सकते हैं इस टूल का एंड इस
टूल का नाम है न्यूक्लि
आई इस टूल का नाम है न्यूक्लि आई इधर मैं
एक मेरा सेशन है उसको भी मैं वो कर देता
हूं तब
तक तो था ही लेट मी ओपन इट जस्ट वेट
गा लेट म ओन इट ठीक है ठीक है ठीक
है चलिए तो अब यहां पर हम यूज करने वाले
हैं न्यूक्लि आई को अब यह न्यूक्लि आई
क्या है आपको मैं यहां पर दिखा देता हूं
यहां पर सिंपली आप काली में जाएंगे ये एक
टूल है एक फ्रेमवर्क है बोल सकते हैं आप
जिसमें मल्टीपल चीजें करने की क्षमता है
काफी चीजें यह कर सकता है काफी सारी चीजें
हैं वो कर सकते हैं हां डुप्लीकेट्स भी
हटा सकते हैं आप डुप्लीकेट्स के बाद आप कर
लीजिएगा तो यहां पे एप्ट लिस्ट न्यूक्लि
पे
चलेंगे यहां देखेंगे कि न्यूक्लि आई
ऑलरेडी काली रोलिंग में इंक्लूडेड है
रिपोजिटरी में तो आप इसको एप्ट इंस्टॉल
न्यूक्लि आई करके एंटर कर दीजिएगा एंड ये
इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा
दैट्ची जिएगा तो यहां पे इसकी हेल्प फाइल
ओपन हो जाएगी जिसमें आपको इसकी पूरी हेल्प
फाइल बहुत लंबी चौड़ी हेल्प फाइल दिखेगी
जिसको देख आपको ज्यादा घबराना नहीं है
बहुत आराम से पेशेंस के साथ काम लेना है
चलिए सिंपल एक न्यूक्लि कमांड टाइप करनी
है उसके बाद एक डोमेन है तो एक डोमेन यहां
पे या एक लिस्ट ऑफ डोमस है आपके पास तो
लिस्ट ऑफ डोमस दे देना है भैया बढ़िया
उसके
बाद नीचे आएंगे यहां पे तो यहां नीचे
आएंगे नीचे आएंगे नीचे आएंगे नीचे आएंगे
नीचे आएंगे नीचे चले आ जाइए चले आइए चले
आइए कहां गए चले आइए चले आइए चले आइए चले
आइए बहुत ज्यादा नीचे आ गए
क्या ओके नीचे आइए नीचे आइए कुछ भी नहीं
है कुछ भी नहीं कहां गया यार नीचे आ जाइए
नीचे आ जाइए नीचे आ जाइए नीचे आ जाइए नीचे
आ जाइए नहीं ऊपर ही चलते हैं ऊपर ही
होगा हां अब यहां पे एक आर्गुमेंट है हाइन
t का जिसका मतलब है टेंपलेट्स आप प्रोवाइड
कीजिए लिस्ट ऑफ टेंप्लेट और टेंप्लेट की
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
को रन करना चाहते हो उस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट
के लिए ठीक है या यहां पे आप रन ओनली न्यू
टेंपलेट्स एडेड आप फन ए0 यूज कर सकते हैं
जो भी नया अब देखो क्या होता है न्यूक्लि
आई जो टूल है ना कैसे काम करता है वो किस
तरीके से यूज में आप ले सकते हैं मल्टीपल
चीजों के लिए बट अभी के लिए सिर्फ मैं
टेकओवर के लिए बता रहा हूं न्यूक्लि
आई गेट पर चलते हैं पेज प यहां पर आ जाते
हैं ए मैं यह वाला सेशन भी स्टार्ट कर
देता हूं जस्ट वेट वेट
वेट
ओके हा जी तो न्यूक्लि य आप आ जाएंगे तो
यहां पर इसकी पूरी रिपोजिटरी है ये एंड
यहां पर इसकी पूरी डिटेल डॉक्यूमेंटेशन है
आपके पास इंस्टॉलेशन का सब कुछ
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन वगैरह दिया हुआ है एंड आप
जब इसी में आप यहां पर ऊपर की तरफ जाएंगे
यहां पर यहां पे तो इसकी सारी फाइल्स जो
है आपको यहां पर दिख रही होंगी यहां प यह
सारी फाइल्स दिख रही है नीचे आ जाएंगे
नीचे आ जाएंगे एंड यहां पे यहां पे वी हैव
डेडिकेटेड रिपोजिटरी दैट हाउसेस वेरियस
टाइप ऑफ लेबिलिटी टेंप्लेट कंट्रीब्यूटेड
बाय मोर दन 300 सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर इनके
पास एक एक न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स का
डायरेक्टरी है बेसिकली न्यूक्लिया एक टूल
है जो कि टेंपलेट्स पर चलती है इनका खुद
का टेंप्लेट है आप खुद के भी टेंप्लेट बना
सकते हो इसमें यह फीचर है एंड उस टेंप्लेट
पे आप न्यूक्लि को चलाओगे तो वो पर्टिकुलर
टेंप्लेट के अंदर जो कोडिंग्स होंगी
वाईएमएल लैंग्वेज में बनी हुई वो चल
जाएंगी जो भी कॉन्फिन जो भी चीजें होंगी
वो चीजें काम करने शुरू कर देंगी ठीक है
चलिए अब देखिए यहां आएंगे टेंपलेट्स में
तो यहां पे आपको बहुत सारे टेंपलेट्स दिख
रहे हैं यहां पे ठीक है ये बहुत सारे
टेंपलेट्स आपको दिख रहे हैं सारे ये देखिए
एसटीडीपी के अ डीएनएस ये सारी चीजें दिख
रही है आपको मान लो एसटीटीपी के अंदर चलते
हैं क्या है कुछ एसटीटीपी के अंदर में अ
यहां पे फिर से यहां पे एचटीटीपी के अंदर
के सारे वनबिल टेक्नोलॉजीज टेक ओवर्स
टेकओवर्स को एक्सपेंड कीजिए तो यहां पे ये
बहुत सारे अलग-अलग तरह के टेक ओवर्स जो है
वो सारे टेक ओवर्स ये टेकओवर्स भी वही है
देखो शफाई का टेक ओवर यहां पे लाइक
स्प्रिंट फूल का टेक ओवर यहां पे ये सारे
टेक ओवर्स भी यहां पे मेंशन है ठीक है
भैया चलिए बढ़िया बात है अब यहां पे आ
जाते हैं अ फजिंग में आ जाते हैं फजिंग
में भी यहां पे बहुत सारे यहां पे
प्रेजेंट है यहां पे डीएनएस में आ जाते
हैं डीएनएस को आपस एक्सपेंड कीजिए तो
डीएनएस वाले सारे आ गए यहां पे फाइल में आ
जाते हैं तो ये फाइल में बहुत सारे यहां
पे आ जाते हैं ठीक है तो देयर आर मल्टीपल
यहां पे आपके टेंपलेट्स जो आपको न्यूक्लि
में मिल जाते हैं न्यूक्लि के अंदर में अब
इसी में मैं क्या करता हूं सब
डोमेन जस्ट वेट गाइस जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट
मैं यहां पे इनको एडमिट कर देता हूं एक
सेकंड
ल
चलिए हा जी तो हो गया हा यहां पर मैं एक ब
मैसेज कर देता
[संगीत]
हूं आई विल बी जॉइनिंग सून प्ली कंटिन्यू
न चलिए तो यहां पर सब डोमेन टेक
ओवर न्यूक्लि
आई टेंपलेट आपको इसका लिंक मिल जाएगा ये
रहा न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स में यहां पे सब
डोमन टेकओवर यहां पे कहां गए भैया है क्या
यहां
पे हम तो यहां पर आ जाते हैं न्यूक्लि आई
टेंपलेट्स वाले डायरेक्टरी प आ जाते हैं
यहां पे एंड ये वाले जो आएंगे इस वाले में
तो बेसिकली ये सब डोमेन टेकओवर वाला जो
न्यूक्लियर टेंप्लेट है यहां पे ये इस
तरीके से इसमें पड़ा हुआ है डिटेक्ट ऑल
टेकओवर्स डवा ये एक टेंप्लेट है ठीक है सब
डोमन टेकओवर का अब इसमें क्या होता है जब
आप न्यूक्लि आई टूल को इंस्टॉल करते हैं
ना इंस्टॉल किया है तो आप जब जाएंगे होम
डायरेक्टरी में होम डायरेक्टरी में हां
होम डायरेक्टरी में चलते हैं यहां पे तो
यहां पर आपको एक डायरेक्टरी दिखेगी यहां
देखो
कॉन्फिन फिग की
कॉन्फिन क्लिया देखने को मिलेगा बट इसके
अंदर कुछ मिलेगा नहीं ठीक है न्यूक्लि
आपको दिखेगा तो सही बट ये न्यूक्लि के कुछ
फाइल्स है कडवा और ये सब फाइल्स है कुछ
चलो पीछे आ जाते हैं अब हमको जाना है लोकल
में एंड न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट करके आपको
डायरेक्टरी दिखेगी इसमें चले जाना है
इसमें आपको सारे वो न्यूक्लि के टेंपलेट्स
हैं जो यहां पे आपको दिख रहे हैं जैसे
डीएनएस के न्यूक्लि के टेंप्लेट सारे
टेंपलेट्स वाई ए एमएल एक्सटेंशन के साथ
आते हैं वाई एमएल ठीक है कोड वाले यहां पे
सीवीज के यहां पे 2023 के सीवीज के कुछ
यहां पे टेंपलेट्स आपको दिख रहे हैं यहां
पे फाइल के कुछ यहां पे ए के बैश के
इलेक्ट्रॉन के कीज मैलवेयर ये सारे के
न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट दिख रहे हैं कुछ
यहां पे हैडलेस है कुछ हेल्पर्स कुछ
एसटीटीपी के यहां पे न्यूक्लियर टेंपलेट्स
आपको दिख रहे हैं यहां पे फजिंग के हैं
यहां पे हनी पॉट के हैं आईओटी के हैं मिस
कॉन्फिन के ओंट के हैं टेकओवर्स वाले भी
यहां पे आपको दिख रहे हैं जो टेकओवर्स बस
आप इसको भी अप्लाई कर सकते हैं बट यहां पे
मुझे जो इस रिपोजिटरी पे ये वाला जो दिख
रहा है ना ये वाला सब डोमेन टेकओवर देखो
डीएनएस है एग्जांपल है फाइल है पैनल्स है
सिक्योरिटी मिस कॉन्फिन है फिर सब डोमेन
टेक ओवर है आपको यहां पे वो नहीं दिखेगी
देखो डीएनएस है फाइल है हेल्पलेस हेल्पर्स
है एसटीडीपी है ये सारे हैं यहां पे बट
यहां पे सब डोमेन टेकओवर आपको कहीं नहीं
दिख रहा है तो कोई बात नहीं नहीं दिख रहा
है तो कोई टेंशन नहीं लेनी हम खुद का ही
बना लेंगे हम क्या करेंगे भाई खुद का बना
लेंगे नहीं दिख रही तो मैं क्या करू खुद
का बनाऊंगा एस सिंपल एस दैट तो अब हम क्या
करेंगे यहां पे यहां पे राइट क्लिक करेंगे
क्रिएट फोल्डर सब
डोमेन टेक ओवर यह हमने एक फोल्डर बना ली
सब डोमेन टेक ओवर की चलिए बढ़िया है अब
हमें इसमें कौन सी फाइल डाल देनी है सब
डोमेन टेकओवर बना के हमें यह वाली डिटेक्ट
ऑल टेकओवर वाली फाइल डाल देनी है तो चलिए
डिटेक्ट ऑल टेकओवर वाली हम जो हमारी
एंट्री है इसको डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं इस
हमारी न्यूक्लि
टेंप्लेट तो हम सब डेमन टेकओवर वाली इसी
में डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं ओपन टर्मिनल मैं
य पर टर्मिनल ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड डब्लू
गेट कर देता हूं एंड यहां पर मैं डाउनलोड
कर देता हूं चलो डाउनलोड कर लिया हमने यह
डिटेक्ट ऑल टेकओवर वा आ चुका हमारे पास तो
यह डायरेक्टरी बन गई अब यहां पर सब डोमेन
टेकओवर वाली जो हम यह टेंप्लेट है इसको हम
यहां पर चला देंगे कैसे चलाएंगे भैया तो
देखिए य यहां पर चलाने के लिए सिंपल सा
फंडा है कैसे चलाना है
न्यूक्लि हाइन एल जिससे आप लिस्ट देंगे जो
आपकी सब डोमेन की लिस्ट है तो मेरे पास है
टेस्ला फाइनल . txt.gz
मल्टीपल सब डोमेन टेक ओवर्स के टेंपलेट्स
डाल दो अभी तो एक है तुम दो तीन डाल दो इस
सारे टेंपलेट्स को एक-एक करके यूटिलाइज
करके आपको रिजल्ट देगा तो हमने क्या किया
हम यहां पे अब हाइन t देंगे सब डोमेन यहां
टेंपलेट्स के
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
ऑफ टारगेट्स एंड हाइन टी टेंप्लेट
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री वही काम कर रहे हैं और
कुछ भी नहीं कर रहे हैं ठीक है तो हमने
क्या किया न्यूक्लि हाइन एल टेस्ला दे
दिया हाइन t से हमने वो डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
[संगीत]
हमने मेंशन कर दी डायरेक्टरी ही बताना है
आपको फाइल वल नहीं बताना है आपको
डायरेक्टरी बताना है बस हो गया बात खत्म
अब इसके साथ-साथ एक यहां पे आपको और भी
आर्गुमेंट देखने को मिलेगा
अ देखिए यहां पे हाइन स्टैट्स आप डिस्प्ले
द स्टेटिस्टिक्स स्टेटिस्टिक्स अबाउट द
रनिंग स्कैन जो स्कैन रन हो रही है उसकी
स्टेटिस्टिक्स अगर देखनी है तो आपको
स्टैट्स लगा देना है वर्वस मोड आउटपुट
देखना है तो हाइन v लगा देना है तो चलिए
हम वर्वस देख लेते हैं तो यहां पे हाइन v
लगा देंगे एंड
दैट्ची सब डोमेन में इसने कोई सब डोमेन
टेकओवर पॉसिबल वलन बिलिटी फाइंड की तो
यहां पर रेड कलर रेड अलर्ट में आपको आ
जाएगा कि यहां पर हाई मतलब प्रोबेबिलिटी
है कि यहां पर सब डोमन टेक ओवर आपको इस पे
पॉसिबल हो सकता है फिलहाल के लिए वार्निंग
वार्निंग अगर व वार्निंग दे रहा है किसी
किसी में जैसे कहीं प वार्निंग दिया हुआ
है तो इसको इग्नोर मार दीजिए इससे कुछ
नहीं है ठीक है ना ये उससे रीच आउट नहीं
कर पा रहा इसलिए वॉर्निंग दे दे रहा है
बाकी ये नॉर्मल सी चल रही है कोई भी इसमें
वने बिलिटी नहीं है फिलहाल के लिए आपको
अगर स्टैट्स देखने हैं तो यहां पे आपको
जैसा कि मैंने दिखाया यहां पे
क्या है ये हाइन स्टैट्स ये लगा दीजिए एंड
आपको स्टैट्स दिखेंगे जो ये रिजल्ट्स आपके
सामने आएंगे उसके स्टैट्स ये दिखाएगा बस
और कुछ भी नहीं है तो ये आपको दिखाएगा
होस्ट ये ये रिक्वेस्ट वन गई 33 पर स्कैन
हो गई है ये चीज करके आप हान v के साथ
स्टैटफील्ड हो जाएगा चलिए ठीक है
दीजे इन्होंने फिर से सुपर चैट किया है
मजा आ गया सर बहुत बढ़िया ट्रेनिंग है
धन्यवाद डीजे अच्छा है मुझे अच्छा लगता है
अगर आपको बेनिफिट मिल रहा है ट्रेनिंग से
अगर यू आर गेटिंग बेनिफिटेड एंड आपको अगर
सीखने को मिल रहा है नॉलेज मिल रही है तो
इससे बड़ी बात कुछ नहीं हो सकती है फॉर मी
टू राइट चलिए तो यह हो गई न्यूक्लि
टेंप्लेट आप यूज कर रहे हैं अब इसमें
अलग-अलग टेंपलेट्स आप देख सकते हैं खोद
सकते हैं एंड न्यूक्लियर टेंपलेट्स को
सप्लीमेंट टेकओवर के लिए आप यूज कर सकते
हैं समझ में आ रहा है
डोंट फाइंड डायरेक्टरी न्यूक्लि आई पहले
इंस्टॉल कर लीजिए न्यूक्लि आई को एक बार
रन कर दीजिए न्यूक्लि इंस्टॉल करके
न्यूक्लियर हाफ को रन कीजिए उसके बाद आप
जाइए होम
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री में जाइए यहां पे एंड
यहां पे शो व्यू पे जाइए एंड व्यू पे जाके
शो हिडन फाइल्स प क्लिक कर दीजिएगा यह जब
क्लिक नहीं रहेगा ना तो आपको हिडन फाइल्स
नहीं दिखेगी रूट में याद रखिएगा शो हिडन
फाइल्स पर क्लिक कीजिए तो आपको सारे हिडन
फाइल्स दिख जाएंगी इसमें लोकल में जाइएगा
न्यू टेंपलेट्स करके आपको दिखेगा इसी में
ये टेंपलेट्स होगी जहां पे हमने एक नई
डायरेक्टरी बना के टेंप्लेट को डाउनलोड
किया है सबमें टेक ओवर वाली सिंपल सी चीज
है समझ में आ गई इतनी चीज गॉट
इट एवरीवन
गॉट ओके ओके सभी लोग समझ गए भैया कि नहीं
समझे ये सब डोमेन टेक ओवर का
फंडा अब मुझे बता दो सब डोमन टेक ओवर कर
लोगे भाई आप लोग आसान है ना बहुत आसान है
बहुत आसान
है सब डोमेन टेकओवर पॉसिबल हुआ तो कैसे
करें बता दिया मैंने भाई आप लेट आए हो
शायद
इसलिए डाटा लेकर स्ट्रीट लाइट के नीचे आकर
ऑनलाइन आया सर थैंक गॉड क्या बात है भाई
यह मतलब भाई विषम पितामह जी
हैं स्ट्रीट लाइट के नीचे से लाइव आ रहे
हैं क्या बात है यार ऐसी अगर जोश और ऐसी
अगर जुनून आपके अंदर है और आप इस तरीके से
इस ट्रेनिंग सेशन को ले रहे हैं इतना
सिंसियर ले रहे हैं सीरियसली ले रहे हैं
तो मैं तो आपको बेस्ट ऑफ द बेस्ट क्वालिटी
दूंगा एंड ऐसे सब लोग हो जाए तो क्या ही
बात है
बढ़िया आसान
है ठीक
है क्लासेस लंबी हो जा रही है बिकॉज एक
टॉपिक को लेकर चल रहे हैं ना तो थोड़ी सी
लंबी हो जा रही है यार अब इसमें क्या कर
सकते हैं मैं बताओ सब टेकओवर को मैंने
बहुत इजी बना दिया है आपके लिए याद रखिएगा
बहुत
इजी सर आज का क्लास मस्त है क्यों और
क्लासेस मस्त नहीं होती क्या भाई बताओ जरा
सब डोमेन टेकओवर को मैंने बहुत इजी बना
दिया है जस्ट रिमेंबर
इट ओके
चलिए चलिए ठीक है तो अब आप अब अच्छा इसमें
लाइक रिएक्ट करने वाले ग कौन-कौन है भाई
रिएक्ट गैंग कौन-कौन है जो
धन्यवाद भाई आप लोगों के सपोर्ट के लिए
इतना सपोर्ट आप दिखा रहे हैं एंड आप लोग
जब कम ओपन करते हैं गाइस कम
चुके हैं वो सिर्फ आपकी वजह से सच बता रहा
हूं सीरियसली एंड दिल से बोल रहा हूं आपकी
वजह से यह चीज हो पाई है एंड ये आ रही है
दैट्ची वीडियोस का रीच भी अच्छा जा रहा है
काफी लोगों तक पहुंच पा रहा है क्योंकि
इतने कम सब्सक्राइबर्स में यहां आना बहुत
बड़ी बात हो जाती है बड़े-बड़े चैनल्स के
यहां पे आते हैं इस जगह पे तो यह चीज जो
है ना आपकी वजह से ही पॉसिबल हो पाया है
आपके सपोर्ट अगर आप ऐसा सपोर्ट दिखाओ यहां
प्रेजेंट रहो हमारे साथ कनेक्ट रहो और बग
बाउंस जाओ पूरा तो
यकीन यकीन के साथ मैं बोल सकता हूं यू विल
बिकम अ प्रो बक बाउंट हंटर एंड यू विल
स्टार्ट गेटिंग बाउंटीज और जब आपको
बाउंटीज या स्वैग या हॉल ऑफ फेम कुछ भी
मिले ना तो इधर को भूलने का नहीं है रि
आपको
उसको बाउंटीज मिला है एंड यह मेरी आपको
मिलेगी बाउंटीज मिलेगा खुशी मुझे होगी
हैप्पीनेस मुझे होगी इनफैक्ट सच में बहुत
ज्यादा हैप्पीनेस होगी आपसे ज्यादा शायद
हैप्पीनेस मुझे होगी कि कोई बंदा फ्री में
आया जिसके पास पैसे नहीं थे अफोर्ड नहीं
कर सकता था बग बांटी की ट्रेनिंग नहीं कर
सकता था एंड उसने इस फ्री कोर्स के कारण
इस फ्री कोर्स को पढ़ के सीख के उसका
दिमाग जब खुला और भी एक्सप्लोर किया उसने
खुद से भी पढ़ा और उसने बाउंट रिवॉर्ड ले
ली
दैट्ची
है आदर्श ठाकुर सर आई फाउंड बग ऑन नासा
ग्रेट आदर्श कांग्रेचुलेशन वेरी वेरी
कांग्रेचुलेशन
आदर्श बढ़िया आदर्श ने फाइंड किया बढ़िया
थैंक यू पंकज यस बहुत सारे लोग टैग करते
हैं मुझे पता है थैंक यू सो मच गाइस
एवरीवन आएगा आएगा आएगा आएगा सब आएगा सब
आएगा इंतजार में
रहो ओके तो यहां पर स्पैमिंग स्पैमिंग अगर
करोगे तो मुझे टाइम आउट करना पड़ेगा प्लीज
डोंट डू फिर मुझे बोल दोगे सर टाइम आउट कर
दिया प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज का आना कोई
जरूरी नहीं है अभी के लिए कोई जरूरी नहीं
है ठीक है हां चलिए तो बस गाइस अ सिंपल
ट्राई हैक मी को भूलना नहीं है ट्राई हैक
मी को भैया ट्राई हैक मी अगर भूल गए तो
फिर तो बड़ा दिक्कत हो जाएगा ट्राई हैक मी
को करते रहिए रेगुलर रहिए ट्राई हैक मी
करते रहिए रेगुलर रहिए ट्राई हैक मी करते
रहिए याद रखिएगा मैंने आपको जो बताया
ट्राई हकमी को छोड़ना नहीं है दूसरी चीज
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक की हमारी एक लाइव थ्री
मंथ्स की लाइव वीकेंड ऑनलाइन ट्रेनिंग जो
है हमने स्टार्ट की है भाई साहब एंड इसकी
लिंक मैंने आपको दे दी है चैट में इस लिंक
को जाइए सेव कर लीजिए बुकमार्क करके रखिए
आप इसको डिटेल्स चेक आउट कीजिए एंड ये
ट्रेनिंग बिल्कुल इन डेप्थ बिगनर टू
एडवांस लेवल होगी अगर आपको एसओसी भी बनना
है देखिए आपको मैंने पहले ही बताया था
लर्निंग पाथ पे जाके अगर आपको एसओसी
एनालिस्ट भी बनना है ना आपको डिस्टल
फॉरेंसिक आना चाहिए जब आप इसके एसओसी
एनालिस्ट वाले यहां पे पाथवे पे जाएंगे तो
आप नीचे जब स्क्रॉल करेंगे तो तो आपको
यहां पे डिजिटल फॉरसिस भी दिखेगी यानी
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक अलग चीज नहीं है साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का ही एक पार्ट है साइबर
सिक्योरिटी डोमेन का ही एक पार्ट है तो ये
ट्रेनिंग 27th जैन से स्टार्ट हो रही है
तीन महीनों के लिए वीकेंड है तो कोई टेंशन
नहीं है आपका कॉलेज है स्कूल है आपका अगर
वर्क है प्रोफेशनल है तो भी कोई दिक्कत
नहीं रिकॉर्डिंग्स मिलेगी हर एक बंदे को
हर सेशन की कोई टेंशन नहीं नहीं देनी है
अगर कोई मिस हो जाती है तो एंड यहां पे
आना है सबसे अफोर्डेबल ट्रेनिंग अभी तक की
आपकी ये डिजिटल फॉसी की है पूरे इंटरनेट
पे आई एम गिविंग यू गारंटी अगर आपको ₹
77000 में कोई इस तरह का कंटेंट और
मॉड्यूल दे दे जिस कंटेंट में वह सारा कुछ
हो जो आपको चाहिए जैसे कि हार्ड डिस्क
फाइल सिस्टम के बारे में जैसे
कि विज फरेंस के बारे में
हम पूरा रिसर्च करके ही ये आपके फी
स्ट्रक्चर लेकर आए हैं मैंने आपको पहले
बोला था मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल और फ्री कंटेंट
ये मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल के अंदर आता है आपको
इसमें भी 3500 ही आपको पे करने हैं प्री
बुकिंग में एक महीने के बाद रिमेनिंग
अमाउंट पे करना है
दैट्ची हमारे डिजिटल फॉर सिक्स का एक
मास्टर क्लास हो रहा है जी हां एक मास्टर
क्लास हो रहा है फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट जिसमें
आपके सारी क्वेरीज को सॉल्व किए जाएंगे
एंड यह हो रही है 15th ऑफ जैन को 15 यानी
परसों शाम को 6:00 बजे
जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट वेट कीजिए मैं आपको लिंक दे देता हूं
इसका एंड जो भी इंटरेस्टेड होंगे दे कैन
कम एंड जॉइन कोई फोर्स नहीं है अगर आपको
इंटरेस्ट है तो
आइए अदर वाइज कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है चलिए
तो मैं यहां पर ्र
का डिजिटल
फरेंस फ्री मास्टर क्लास मैं इसका एक लिंक
दे देता हूं एंड यू कैन
जवाइन विद दिस लिंक हमारे ् ग्रुप में
डायरेक्टली जवाइन कर सकते हैं एंड देन यू
कैन कम
एंड अटेंड आवर मास्टर क्लास ठीक है आप
अटेंड कर सकते हैं बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ फस्ट
होगा ठीक है एंड एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं
चलिए वो मैं अभी बता नहीं सकता टी एचएम के
बारे में ज्यादा कुछ यहां पे बता नहीं
सकता सॉरी आपको जब मैसेज आए टे ग्रा प
आपको मैसेज जब आते हैं तो आप लोग रिप्लाई
नहीं करते हैं टी एचएम वाउचर के
रिगार्डिंग कुछ भी आपको मैसेज आता है तो
यू डोंट रिप्लाई तो इसलिए आप t ग्रा प
रिप्लाई किया कीजिए जब भी आपको ई मैसेज
आता है हमारी टीम के साइड से एंड डील वहां
पे आप बात कर सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
वहां पे आप टेंशन मत लीजिए आराम से बात
कीजिए ठीक है ऑफिशियल एस को टीएन मैंने
बता रखा है का हैंडल ठीक है दैट
इट चलिए लव फ्रॉम वेस्ट बंगाल सर लव फ्रॉम
इंडिया ब्रदर इंडिया बिहार सब जगह से आपको
बहुत सारा प्यार एंड आज के सेशन को बस
यहीं पे एंड करते हैं गाइस थैंक यू सो मच
फॉर जॉइनिंग दिस सेशन एंड मेकिंग दिस सेशन
वंडरफुल आपके बिना ये सेशन बिल्कुल अधूरा
है तो ज्यादा से ज्यादा लोग लाइव में आया
कीजिए ताकि मजा आए मुझे भी एंड इस सेशन को
और भी इंटरेस्टिंग बनाया जा सके और भी
यूजफुल कंटेंट जो है आपके सामने लाया जा
सके ठीक है तो धन्यवाद भाई सबके लिए सबको
यहां पे आने के लिए सबको जॉइन करने के लिए
एंड हमारे सोशल मीडिया हैंडल्स पे जरूर आ
जाइएगा ये आपका linkedinsign.com
[संगीत]